احد الاصدقاء ارسل تجربه الشخصيه يقول انا
دخلت تسهيلات همم
مدعومه بكفاله من بنك الرياض وقعونا احنا
الشركاء يعني اخذنا مثلا مليون ريال
ههه
يقول اخذنا مليون ريال ااا
لنفترض انهم خمسه شركاء مقسمين بالتساوي
عشان بس نبسطتها كل واحد منهم يقول كل
واحد مننا وقعوه سند لامر ما هو بحجم حصته
يعني
رياض عنده ضمان 80% من كفاله وعنده ضمان
خمسه مليون ريال من الشركه على على قرار
تراه هي انت تقول بس انا ما راح احصل من
كل واحد منهم لكن هي زي ما قلت لك هي تحمل
البنك بس الرعب انا انا حاطط رسمه في
الشركه اقل من هذا عشان بياخذ مليون
هذه مرعبه
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا اعمل جريس
يستضيف قاعده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده
الراي وسولف معهم على المستجدات ومستجدات
السعوديه 2030 في حلقه اليوم طارق السدحان
رئيس التنفيذي لبنك الرياض في حلقه سابقه
من فودكاست سقراط كان ضيف لمديريه تطوير
مدير برنامج تطوير القطاع المالي احد
برامج تحقيق الرؤيه واللي غطى التحول في
القطاع من زاويه نظر الحكومه
الحلقه هذه حتى غطي التحول من زاويه نظر
القطاع الخاص واهم مكون في القطاع الخاص
المالي هي البنوك في البدايه عرفنا ايش
يعني
كيف نموذج
ارباحهم لما نفتح قائمه ارباح البنك وايش
اكبر جزء همم من مصادر الارباح للبنوك
بعدين دخلنا على دورهم في تحقيق رؤيه
السعوديه 2030 من خلال همم
مثل زياده نسبه اغراض المنشات الصغيره
متوسطه
منخفضه جدا عندنا وايش العوائق اللي
موجوده فيها همم كيف زياده الفت الماضيه
ايش اللي تغير حتى تزيد ليش لسه في ضمانات
قاسيه والبعض يعتبرها مجحفه مطلوبه من
شركاء الشركات الصغيره متوسطه عشان ياخذون
قروض مضمونه من الدوله همم تشرفنا على هذا
الموضوع تكلمنا عن قطاع التقنيه الماليه
هل هو مهدد ولا مكمل للبنوك كيف تتصرف
البنوك للتعامل مع هذا المستجد الجديد في
القطاع همم
وايش المشهد في 20 30 كيف هتكون حصه
متوزعه ما بين البنوك وما بين الشركات
التقنيه الماليه تكلمني عن القروض
العقاريه قروض الافراد همم هل البنك مستمر
في الاقراض هيهدد الاقراض هيزيد الاقراض
نظرا للمستجدات اللي صارت في موضوع اسعار
الفائده عالميه هل وصلنا لمستويات همم
مقلقه من حيث الانتشار على قطاع القروض
العقاريه والمخاطر
ااا من من التعثر لا سمح الله في هذا
القطاع هل ساهمت البنوك في رفع اسعار
الاراضي والوحدات السكنيه ااا في رياض
تحديدا والمملكه عموما تكلمنا ايضا عن
دورهم في القطاع السياحي والقطاع الثقافي
من خلال صناديق التنمويه اللي تاسست حديثه
وغطينا عده نقاط مرتبطه بالمشهد العالمي
ارتفاع نسب الفائده كيف يؤثر على السيوله
داخل السعوديه يشتغل البنك المركزي في
التعامل مع هذا التحدي مش قراءه همم ضيفنا
لهذا الامر وبعد ذلك
مجموعه من اسئلتكم الثمينه اللي قد تكون
مرتبطه بالضيف نفسه اهم دروس التحول اللي
عاش اثناء قياده البنك همم او على البنك
نفسه نفسه شو اخبار البرج الجديد حقهم همم
الشكوى اللي من بعض موظفين الفروع تجاه
البنك واتجاه البيئه العمل في البنك بشكل
عام همم ونقاط اخرى عديده اترك الحوار
حياك الله ابو خالد شرفت ويسلمك شكرا لك
شكرا على الدعوه وان شاء الله يكون لقاء
يعني خفيف ومفيد باذن الله انا متاكد انه
مفيد بس بعرف الحقيقه خفيف ههه
خصوصا اذا بديناها بالحلا وبالك
احلى محل تشاكلت في الرياض لان ما بسوى
خذ راحتك
انا
والله ما اعرف بس انا انا
يعني ما يحب ذلك الاسد
بين الحلو وبين همم يعني جسم رياضي او جسم
صحي
ودي انه جسم رياضي لكنه همم يعني شفت كل
شيء في الحياه التوازن فيه زين يعني ال ال
التوسط في كل شيء كل الحلا يعني اكل يوميا
ترى يوميا يوميات الله
اخرتها ههه
لا علاقتي مع الحلا علاقه خربت البيت يعني
البيت مليان دائما
حتى عيال الصغار يعني
يحبون الحلقه كل اطفال كل البشر يحبوا رغم
همم يعني من عشاق رسلت تتحكم فيه تحط
لكلمه للاطفال لانه لو فتحوا لانه صحيح لا
لا اكيد لا لا اكيد انه في في نمت مسموح
فيه ما حبه واحده تنحط توكل على طول بس بس
اوكي اوكي الكبير
هذول فريق المالح
طريق الموانح فلما نطلب حلا دائما اكل
نصيبه انا يعني ما يضيع شيء ههه
رئيس التنفيذي لبنك الرياض ااااه
ويعني اول قاعده القطاع المصرفي الخاص
اللي نستضيفهم في سقراط وهو قطاع جدا مهم
جدا
عشرات التداخلات مع الرؤيا فاحنا هنغطيها
كلها بس ابتداء خلينا نعرف الناس اللي ما
يعرفون ايش يعني قطاع مصرف ايش يعني بنك
الكل احتك بلوك بس لبعض ما يعرف ايش يصير
جوه هذا البنك
بالاتصال طيب البنك ببساطه يعني البنك هو
محرك اقتصادي كبير في البلد يربط ما بين
همم حمله الوداع
السيول الموجوده في البلد مع الفرص
الاستثماريه الي في البلد
في ناس عندها سيوله مواطنين وشركات وجهات
حكوميه الزائده فلوس فلوس
عندهم
البنك هو الجهه الي توضع هذه الفلوس عندها
او توضع فيها بشكل حسابات جاريه او ودائع
استثماريه
البنك ياخذ هذه
ويشغلها بطريقه اخرى في جهات اخرى قطاع
اخر من
الاقتصاد اللي هو نتكلم سوا عن الشركات او
افراد عندهم حاجه للسيوله فهو يربط ما بين
الوثر مع الحاجب السيوله فبالتالي يصير
فيه حركه اقتصادي عمليات استثماريه مشاريع
جديده في البلد فانا وصل لهم البنك يكون
هو وزير التوصيل السيوله لهذه طبعا لما
تنظر للبنك او
نطاق اعمال البنك او ال- الادارات اللي في
البنك
في اربع ادارات رئيسيه في في كل بنك يمكن
الان في نتكلم عن اداره خامسه ممكن
نتطرقنا بعدين لكن ما في شك انه في قطاع
مصرفيه الافراد وهذا القطاع المسؤول عن
خدمه الافراد من فتح الحسابات والودائع
وكيف يديروا حساباتهم وكيف يقدمون الخدمات
للعملاء هذولي وايضا عندهم الاقرار
الاقراض بكل اشكاله الاقراض الاستهلاكي
لاقراض العقاري اقراض التمويل السيارات
ااقراض الكريدت كارد
بطاقات الائتمان
ثم عندك القطاع الثاني هو القطاع الشركات
ايضا يخدم قطاع الشركات بما فيها الشركات
فتح حساباتها عمليات المصرفيه كلها وايضا
اقراض الشركات الشركات الكبيره تتكلم عن
ارامكو سابك اس تي سي الى الشركات الصغيره
متوسطه ومتناهيه الصغر هذه كلها تحت مظله
القطاع الثالث اللي دائما في المهم جدا في
القطاع المصرفي قطاع الخزينه قطاع الخزينه
هذا اللي يسوي
البلنسنج ما بين السيول الفائده اللي
تكلمنا عنها او السيوله الموجوده
واحتياجات القطاع هو اللي يمسك همم
محفظه البنك كامله ويقول انا عندي والله
400 مليار
ال- ال- القطاع مصرفيه الشركات ياخذ منها
كذا قطاع مصرفيه الافراد ياخذ منها كده
وكم يبقى منها جزء يستثمر للبنك كاستثمار
همم يعود بعوائد البنك لكن ايضا سهل
التسييل وقليل المخاطر بحيث انه متى ما
احتجت اني اعطي للاقراض اكثر بامكان
المنزل
لما نشوف مثلا قطاع مصرفيه الشركات انه في
نمو حركه اقتصادي كبير الان فيخصص جزء
لمسرحيه الشركات اكبر لما لما نتكلم عن
القطاع التمويل العقاري والسنوات الماضيه
كان فيها حراج الكبير يخصص همم جزء ايضا
من ال- من السيوله البنك للقطاع العقاري
والقطاع الرابع القطاع الرابع هو القطاع
الاستثماري يعني هو اللي هو الكابيتال همم
مثلا عند في حالتنا احنا عندنا الرياضه
الماليه سابقا هذا القطاع كان تحت مظله
الاستثمار كاني وشركات يعني مقسومه اذا
قسمين جزء من البنك في 2007 2008 لما
انشات هيئه سوق المال وبدات تنظيم عمل سوق
المال همم فصل هذا القطاع الى شركات
استثماريه همم سواء مملوكا لبنوك او غير
مملوكه لبنوك تقوم باعمال الاستثمار
بحيث انه تبكن العملاء اللي عندهم ايضا
فائض سيوله حابين يستثمرون انه يستثمرون
عن طريق الجهات الجهات يعني هل هذه
الممارسه للسائله في العالم والله شف انه
ما يجتمع النشاط الاقراضي مع النشاط
الاستثماري شوف كان في موجه عالميه انه في
الفصل كان الموجه هذه بدها ترجع سوريا
يمكن البنك اكثر في مواضيع الاستثمار
اعتقد انه لكل مرحله همم من تطوير القطاع
المالي همم
اعتقد انه الهيكل المناسب جيدا ان احنا
همم شركات استثماريه تنظمها سوق المال تحت
مظله البنوك او او مستقله يعني في شركات
استثماريه كثيره وناجحه ما شاء الله همم
ما هي مرتبطه بشكل كامل فهذه عنده
منتجاتها للاستثماريه سوي الصناديق
الاستثماريه مضيق الاسهم الصناديق
العقاريه صناديق الملكيه الخاصه
البرايبتكوتي همم وعندها برضو الجانب
الاستثماري البسمت بانكينج مثل همم
الطروحات الاي بي يو وهذا اللي ينطبق على
تقريبا 14 بنك في السعوديه اليوم طيب همم
بهذا النموذج في احن بنوك تصير بس بنك
الاستثماري تقريبا بلوك جاي من بره بالضبط
الاجنبيه الموجوده في السوق هم عندهم رخصه
كامل كامله
موجود في البلد
لازم يكون عندك شبكه فروع قويه لازم تكون
عارف
الاحتياجات المواطن كيف يعني انت بناء
الخبره هذه ما هو بسيط يعني تتكلم عن بحث
لما تيجي جديد تقول بادخل انافس في السوق
فما هيكون تحدي كبير جدا فمعظم البنوك
الاجنبيه وفروع البنوك الاجنبيه لانشات في
المملكه كانت تركيزها على الكوره
وش علاقتكم بالبنك المركزي ابونا البنك
المركزي البنك المركزي طبعا هو المنظم
للقطاع المصري وتتكلم عن قطاع المالي
المصرفي بشكل يعني ال ال البنك المركزي
اليوم ينظم عمل البنوك ينظم عمل شركات
التامين وينظم عمل شركات تمويل وكل
القطاعات المرتبطه بالثلاثه
محاور رئيسيه ك- او ال جهات الرئيسيه طبعا
البنك البنك المركزي هو الوحيد
طبعا
الدوله زي ما تعرف اخو عمر الريال مربوط
بالدولار
فبالتالي هو يضمن ايضا استماريه الربط هذا
السمراريه قوه عمله نكب الريال السعودي ان
يكون قوي
واستثمار الفوائد ال ال الفائضه عن عن
الدوله في محافظ الاستثمار حق البنك
المركزي لكن لما نتكلم عن القطاع الاشرافي
اللي يمسنا نحنا كبنك
البنك المركزي هو المنظم للقطاع المالي في
السعوديه هو اللي يصدر التشريعات هو اللي
يحمي همم الودائع حق العملاء هو اللي يضمن
ان شاء الله يعني وعلى مدى سنوات طويله
همم السنهوريه في القطاع المصرف السعودي
بشكل صحي قوي جدا يعني الحمد لله مرينا
بازمات كبيره تتكلم
عن ازمه همم 2008 اللي عانت وشفنا افلاسات
بنوك فيها الحمد لله القطاع المصرفي كان
يعني بمعزل عن التبعات هذا لانه فعلا
عندنا منظم قوي وعارف كيف يحمي القطاع
المصرفي بشكل كامل
وامانه يعني البنك المركزي ما هو مجامله
لهم والله اييه
بشهاده
المنظمات الدوليه اللي تنظم العمل البنوك
سواء البي اي اس او الفاينش استبلتي بورد
دائما كان يفوز بجوائز انه واحد من افضل
منظمين في العالم يعني نفخر انه عندنا
منظم لقطاع مصرفي من الافضل في العالم واش
نموذج همم الدخل بالنسبه للبنوك يعني انت
مليون بنك كانت تقوم بالعلاقه بين
هالطرفين وش نموذج الربحيه همم
البنك يحقق ارباحها يعني من اكثر من مصدر
دخل هامه طبعا الانترست
الفوائد اللي تتعمل على الجروب مثلا لو
اخذنا الاقراض كمصدر دخل احنا نقرا ب-
فوائد معينه الفوائد هذه تفك كبير جدا من
دخل البنك بعدين رسوم الخدمات يعني اتكلم
عن رسوم خدمات البطاقات رسوم الخدمات اللي
تفرض على التعاملات بالعمله الاجنبيه همم
وايضا في في محفظه الخزينه عندك دخل
الاستثمار اللي يجيء لك من تم الاستثمار
همم فوائد السيوله اللي عندك في البنك من
الرياض الماليه
عن طريق ادارتهم للمحافظ هذه هو استثمارهم
ايضا يدخل عوائد البنك لكن لما تشوف مثلا
القائمه الدخل البنك هتلقى الانترستيانكم
او دخل العملات همم هو اعلى دخل كم في
المئه لا يمثل الجزئيه كبيره جدا من داخل
البنك يمكن تصل الى فوق ال 80% داخل البنك
بعدين تجيء داخل الفيل اللي هو زي ما ذكر
الرسوم اللي تفرضها البنوك مقابل تقديم
الخدمات بعدين همم
ارباح الاستثمار وارباح الاستثمار الخزينه
او من من الذراع الاستثماري همم الرياض
الماليه
في البنوك او او في زياده السيوله او في
ناقص السيوله او همم حبايب بلوك نفسهم
يصير في تعاملات هذه بس نوضعها طيب احنا
احنا في حاجه عندنا في القطاع المصرفي
اللي اسمها السايبر السايبر هو نسبه
الاقراض ما بين البنوك وهذه دائما تحدد كم
العائد على السيوله وكل بنك فوق السايبر
هذا يحط النسبه اللي يراها مناسبه مبنيه
على المخاطر حق ال المشروع او حق الشركه
او حق الفرد في حاله الافراد يحط له نسبه
همم عوائد عليها طبعا البنك المركزي دوره
انه يتاكد ان القطاع المصري فيه موجود
وقادر انه يدعم
ويؤدي دوره في دعم الاقتصاد لما يصير في
فتره من الفترات والله في السيوله هنا
يجيء بنك المركزي يتدخل بخصي ولك في
القطاع المصرفي ايضا على شكل ودائع على
شكل وداع في البنوك وياخذ عليها فائده
منكم في حالات ياخذ عليها فائده في حالات
ما ياخذ عليها يعني حسب حسب وضع الاحتياج
حسب
برنامج حجه الفتره اللي ضخت فيها السيوله
همم فبالتالي تسمى همم نسبه اللي هي من
البنك المركزي
للوداع هذه هي هذه ودائع تودع بطريقه
تعزز السيوله في البنوك تمكني انا من
الاقراب بشكل اكبر حلو
دور مهم جدا انه انا كمان اني اكمل في دعم
المسيره الاقراض يعني مثلا الحمد لله
اليوم في مع رؤيه 20 30
الزخم الاقتصادي عالي جدا
في المحور الثالث
عندكم بالضبط
صكوك والسندات انت دائما مثلا في العام
الماضي 22 كثير من البنوك اصدرت صكوك
سندات عشان تساعد الحركه اللي صاير في
الاقتصادي اللي صاير في البلد بفلوس وهذا
نوع اختراعه هي اقترضت من المجتمع كان
يقترضت انا عشان اعزز راس مالي طبعا البنك
المركزي برجع للوداع حق الملكيه المركزي
لكن البنك المركزي لما اا ينظر لملائه
البنوك ينظر الى ملاءاتها الماليه عنده
معادله يسموها كفايه راس المال وهذه
مختلفه ما هي وحده لكل بنك كل بنك على
مستوى مخاطره توسعه في اقراض معين يضع
البنك المركزي دراسه كامله يسويها لمده
يعني تاخذها ثلاث شهور دراسه هذه ونقاشات
كبيره مع البنت لين يصل الى مرحله يحدد لك
انت مستوى كفايه راس مالك نسبه معينه من
راس مالك
وهذه النسبه هي اللي تعطيك انت كم استطيع
اني استطيع النمو بالاقراض او لا
ومرتبطه ايضا بالكابتل بالاصدارات الصكوك
اللي تحسب في الكابيتال ايضا في محدد ثاني
وهذا اللي بربطه بس بالوداع حق السامه او
البنك المركزي انه في نسبه برضه من ال ال
ال ال
المعايير الرقبيه عند البنك المركزي هي
نسبه القروض للودائع احنا عندنا في البنك
المركزي 90% ما تتجاوز 90 بسط لي اياها
90% من الوداع اللي عندك انا عندي ودائع ب
300 مليار ما اقدر اقرض الا 90% من الحجم
هذه
وهذه والباقي ال 10%
احتياط تستثمرها اي ممكن تستثمرها ممكن
تستثمرها لك تبقى عندك في استثمارات قليله
المخاطر لك هاي تبقى كحمايه لودائع
العملاء اوكي يعني ما يبغوا ما يبغوا
البنوك تتوسع في الاقراض مثلا هذا هو عرف
في كل العالم
همم البنك المركزي الدولي والبيئه
ثانيه
تقول لك انت لا تتجاوز مثلا ال 110% اذا
هذا السياسه
يقول لك لا تتجاوز ممكن يقول لك بريطانيا
او امريكا
[موسيقى]
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اللي هي 90%
يعني ممكن البنك المركزي في دوله اخرى
يتدخل مع بنك معين لما يشوف انه نسبه
اغراضه للوداع تجاوز ال 110 يعني وين قاعد
تقرا اكثر دخلت الوداع حق العملاء في
مخاطر فحلنا النسبه هذه 90% اعتقد ان يعني
الحمد لله تحمي المودعين وتعطي البنوك
اريحيه في النمو في الاغراض قبل ما انتقل
لي حكايه التحول همم اليوم اكثر حديث
الناس على موضوع الارتفاع اسعار الفائده
صحيح اللي بتبدا من الفدرالي الامريكي
وتنعكس على كل العالم ودي افهم مش علاقتها
احنا الامريكي ليش احنا تاثر فيه مع
اقتصادنا ما في مشاكل اللي عند امريكا
وقاعدين نتاثر فيهم والحاجه الثانيه ليش
هذا الشيء يؤدي الى نق سيوله همم اللي
اليوم يحكن عندنا الناس ابي اجاوب يعني
بطريقه مبسطه يا ريت احنا عملنا مرتبطه
بالدولار 3.75 هذا سعر الصرف من من اكثر
من 40 30 سنه اكثر من 30 سنه
فبالتالي عشان احافظ على الارتباط هذا
لازم يكون همم
السايبر قريب من اللايبر السايبر زي ما
بدك هو نسبه الاقراب ما بين البنوك
الداخليه واللايبر هو نسبه الاقتراض ما
بينهم دوليه
همم فبالتالي متى ما اختلف صار في مسافه
ما بين السايبر مثلا ثلاثه ونصف واللايبر
اربعه ونصف صافي فرق ايش معناته هذا انه
لما حط ودائع في البنوك في السعوديه
هتعطيني تقريبا قريب من الثلاثه ونص في
المئه لكن لما اعطي احطه ودائع في بنوك
اجنبيه هتعطيني اربعه ونصف ومش بيسوي هذا
بيطلع من السعوديه برا المملكه
فانت ما تبغى تصير تطلع برا المملكه
فبالتالي انا بحافظ على السيوله هذه
فدائما اضمن انه والعكس صحيح يعني انا ما
ابغى برضه السايبر يصير اعلى فبالتالي كله
ايضا اييه تبعت اقتصاديه ما هي الجيده
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء الاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
الدول اللي عملتها مربوطه سواء مباشره
دائما
احجم التضخم هذا بني اسحب السيوله بالسوق
هي عرض الطلب
لانه لما تصير الانترا تعالي يصير
الاقتراض مكلف بيجي عمر يقول انا والله
باقترض عشان اشتري سياره
لو كان القرض هذا بواحد في الميه سهل عليك
انك تخثر وتحكيش السياره لما يكون القرض
هذا بيكلفك 6% تقول لا والله ماني بنشتري
السياره الحين بصبر سنتين لما ينزل فلما
انت تقرر انك ما تشتري السياره هذه قل
الطلب على السيارات فبالتالي بينخفض اسعار
السيارات بينخفض التبخر لما تسحب السيوله
من السوق
الطلب على المنتجات حيقل فبالتالي العرض
والطرف لا ينخفضه
اسهم اهي يعني موالها انا بقرض صحيح اذا
ارتفعت الفائده وصار مكلف في المحفظه هذا
الفرق
من الاستثمار وتكلفه التمويل عليك مو غير
مجدي فبالتالي تسحبها همم فهذا هذا هذا
السبب اثر اخر اللي هو اغراء تكلفه
البديله بمعنى سابقه لو انت بتسوي مشروع
مطعم مثلا بيدخلك في المئه في السنه بكل
ما فيها من مخاطر ومعاناه وتحديات اليوم
لو تحطها وديعه بتعطيك 6%
6% بدون مخاطر بالضبط
بالضبط بالضبط
الان انا بدي ادخل ابو خالد على حكايه
التحول اللي هي
علاقه تحديد بنك الرياض باللي قاعد يصير
في التحول في في السعوديه تحت رؤيه
السعوديه 2030 وخليني ابدا اسالك انتم
بانكيش لانه بنك الراجحي يقول احنا بنك
الافراد البنك الاهلي يقول احنا اكبر بنك
في راس المال انتم افضل بنك في ايش احنا
افضل بنك اشياء كثيره احنا طبعا شوف بنك
الرياض عرفت همم على مدى التاريخ انه بنك
من اروع البنوك في خدمه قطاع الشركات
يعني البنك ما في شك انه في فتره دعم
انقطاع المقاولات بشكل كبير في المملكه
كيف يمكن هذا سبب ارتباط الاسم بنك
المقاولين انه كان المقاول يعرف انه بنك
الرياض عنده خبرات متميزه اللي بتدرس طلبه
بشكل سريع وبيكون رد عليها سريع
بنك الرياض على تاريخيا معروف انه بنك همم
بنك يقدم خدمات بشكل رائع لقطاع الشركات
يمكن كان في فتره فتره من الفترات ايضا
المصرفيه الافراد في بنك الرياض
رغم حجم البنيه التحتيه القويه اللي في
بنك الرياض مثلا اذا تنظل عدد الفروع
وتنظر لعدد مكان الصرافه والنقاط البيع او
عدد الزملاء والزميلات في البنك في مصرفيه
الافراد تجد انه بنيه تحتيه قويه لكن ما
كان في تركيز كبير عليها فما كان بنك
الرياض يعرف بنك مصرفيه افراد كان دائما
همم
وكان بنك ما شاء الله له السبق في في
الكورفت واضافه ان الكوربه تحديدا ايضا
كان يعرف بحاجتين ثانيه انه بنك الحكومه
وبنك المنشات الصغير المتوسط
حتى في استراتيجتنا الجديده في البنك لما
جينا في مجتمعون
اللي عنده الحكومه
ركزنا على مصرفيه المصرفيه الحكوميه
تحديدا لما اعلنت الرؤيه في 2016 يعني
تبين لنا انه فعلا هيكون في مبادرات لازم
يكون للقطاع المالي دور كبير فيها همم
يسهم في نجاح الرؤيه بشكل كبير
وصادفت ايضا انه مصرفيه المنشات الصغيره
متوسطه اللي احنا الحمد لله بدينا فيها من
2004 وعندنا يعني خبره كبيره بنيناها من
تقريبا حوالي 19 سنه مكنتنا انه برضه احنا
نعزز تواجدنا في دعم المنشات الصغيره
متوسطه في فتره
من مؤمن من من المستهدفه الرؤيه دعم
القطاع هذا ودعم مبكناته فاحنا دعمنا في
فتره ما كان فيها دعم وكان القطاع هذا
عالي المخاطر جدا فلما تيجي تتكلم اليوم
في 2023 وكيف الايكو سيستم بالكامل بدعم
المنشات الصغيره متوسطه قاعد يتحسن بشكل
رائع
فما في شك انه الجميع يتنافس الان على طيب
بدامك فتحتها الموضوع ابو خالد انا ودي
افهم المشهد لانه هذا من تحديات برنامج
تطبيق قطع المالي احد برامج تحقيق كانت
وثيقته اللي صدرت في 2018 تتكلم على ان
واحده من تحديات القطاع المصري في
السعوديه انهم نصيب المنشات الصغيره
المتوسطه من الاجمالي الاقرار لا يتعددتهم
في المئه صحيح فقط كانت نسبه منخفضه جدا
جدا
في 2025 بس انا بدي افهم ايش سبب احجام
البنوك اصلا عن الانقراض متوسطه رغم انها
في
زي كل الجنوبيه 80% من قروض البنوك صحيح
هي المشروع المتوسطه احنا عندنا الهرم
مقلوب مقلوب صحيح شوف هي مرتبطه بالمخاطر
انا كقطاع مصرفي بنا في نشاط عالي المخاطر
فلما اجيء على المخاطر انتم اكثر قطاع ما
في مخاطر
عندك
فلما يصير فيه دي فولت معين في همم في همم
عميل او معانا في نشاط معين انت تتضر بشكل
كبير يعني شوف مثلا في 2020
القطاع المصرفي
في العالم تضرر بشكل كبير جدا القطاع
المصري في السعوديه لما تقارن الارقام
19 ب 20 او 20 21 هتجد انه 20 كانت الاسوه
لانه البنوك اضطرت ان تاخذ مخصصات لانه
متوقع انه تعثرات كبيره في الانسجه وكانت
تحديدا المنشات الصغيره المتوسطه
متناهيه الصغر مافي شك انه قطاع عالي
المخاطر
واحد بادي نشاط جديد انت تقييم خبره الشخص
هذا في في اداره العمل هذا النشاط اللي هو
داخله اساس النشاط كيف الدنيا مكس حقته هل
هو مربح همم يمكن من الاشياء الجميله اللي
صارت في مع التحول حق الرؤيه 20
30% الى 7% طيب انت بعطيك اكثر من مثال
لكن انا انا اتذكرها بشكل قريب لانه كنت
في البنك المركزي وقتها وفي لجنه شباب
الاعمال وكنا ننظر ايش المعوقات اللي
يواجهها الصغار المستثمرين او او
المبادرين الانتربلرز التمويل واحده منها
لكن ما كان اولويه ما كان رقم واحد ولا
اثنين ولا ثلاثه كان التمويل يجي احيانا
اثنين ثلاثه ثلاثه عفوا يجي اربعه لكن في
تحديات تنظيميه اكثر لما تنظر
لواحد بدنا نشاطه كان يقول لك تحديات
بدايه النشاط صعب متطلبات الحكوميه كثيره
الرسوم الحكوميه كثيره الزكاه والدخل
المتعبه فيجيء يحط لك سعوده والعمل فيها
تحديات كبيره
اعتقد انه منشات
والكل منظومه كامله حق وزاره التجاره
اشتغلت بشكل كبير على تسهيل العمليات هذه
فبالتالي
يمديه ينجح نسب نجاحه بشكل كبير
اعلى من ما كانت عليه في 2014 2015
فبالتالي انت لما تقيم مخاطر كل واحد جاي
يقترض منك انت بتقيمها ياخذني والله نسبه
مخاطر 70% في هذا الوقت لما الان تيجي
تغير نسبه مخاطر مثلا نزلت مثلا 50%
فبالتالي انت تحسنت عندك البيئه التنظيميه
فبالتالي انا اكثر جراه في تمويل هذا
النشاط
هذا سبب سبب ثاني الدعم الحكومي في مثلا
يعطيك مثال برنامج كفاله برنامج كفاله من
انجح في وجهه نظري البرامج اللي بدات في
وقت همم وقصه نجاح امانه في دعم وتمكين
المنشات الصغيره المتوسطه لما تيجي جهه
حكوميه وتقول تعال
القطاع هذا وانا اضمن لك بنسبه 80% انت
مخاطرك بس 20% انا اعطي عميل مليون ريال
لا قدر الله فشل المشروعه انا برجع 800
متر وبتحمل 200,000
لكن برضه كانت كفاله يعني تخلي البنوك
تتنافس فلما انت تصير تقييمك جيد العميل
هذا ودعمك برضه لو جيد انه ينجح همم وتنجح
في كثير ولا يصير عندك نسب همم ديفولت
عاليه اعطيك حصه اكبر من برنامج كفاله
فصارت البنوك تتنافس في اختيار العملاء لو
توجيههم مساعدتهم بشكل كبير ااه كفاله
ونجاحها في مع رؤيه 20 30 تكررت لكن على
صناديق ايطاليه بتكلم عن الصندوق التنميه
السياحي عند الصندوق رائع هذا بالجيها بس
قبل كفاله فيها اسئله كثير همم الان كفاله
صار تحت المنشات الصغيره
وهنا السؤال يعني كفاله او قروض المشاعات
عاده اعلى في نسبه الفائده
مع انها مضمونه لكم لانه فائدتها اعلى
الشيء الاسود حسب يعني ضمانات
يعني انت غير ضمان الشركه نفسها ما اخذ
الضمان كفاله بعدين توقع كل شريك على سند
لامر نعمه فهذه يعني فيها اجحاف خصوصا
شركات ذات مساله محدوده كلمه كبيره بس
لانك انت الثلاثه ليرز او ثلاثه يعني
مستويات من التحوض بطريقه تخلي كثير يعني
انا عارف حالات الشبكه كلهم بدهم يخترضون
واحد منهم يقول لنا موقع سند لامر
فعطس رائحه الشركه نتيجه
سبب انها ذات مسؤوليه محدود عشان ما في
يرجع عليه شخصيه ليش يجي البنت اللي
الثمانين في الميه كفاله فلوسه ويوقعني
سنه طيب خليني اعطيك انا
السيناريو حق الاقرار في البنوك انا لما
اجي اقرا اول هدف انظر له او اول شيء انظر
له انه قدره العميل على السداد كمصدر
السداد بالنسبه لي هذا بريرتي وهذا اللي
يخليني في بعض الحالات زي ما قد انا ممكن
اقبض بدون ضمانات تماما لا ضمانات عقاريه
ولا ضمانات اسهم ولا حتى سند لامر لما
يكون مشروع هذا واضح انه ما شاء الله
مشروع ناجح او عقود مستمره
موجوده موجوده
مصدر السداد واضح القدره الائتمانيه
للعميل واضحه خبره موجوده نفذ المشاريع
هذه من قبل
ما نطلب فيها لا سندي امر لا ضمانات
عقاريه لا ضمانات استثماريه ولا شيء نطلب
ابدا نعتمد على مصادر الدخل حق العميل
والقدره الماليه والكشف له حقه هذه صارت
مع كفاله
بموضوع كفاله انا ما اروح الكفاله لان انا
عندي شك لانه كفاله تشاركني الربح
فانا ما اروح الكفاله الا في الحالات اللي
فعلا انا عندي قلق كبير من العميل هذا ما
هو قادر لكن لما اكون انا مطمن ان العميل
هذا الصغير او المتوسط
قادر على انه يوقف نفسه انا بموله بدون ما
احتاج كفاله لانه زي ما قلت لك انا كفاله
شاركك الريفي لانه يتحمل المخاطر فطبيعي
اني شايفك في الربح فانا لما اكون مرتاح
من المخاطر ما راح كفاله وهو شركات صغيره
متوسطه واقدر ارفع الطلب والكفاله وكفاله
بتوافق لي عليه لكن ما ارفعها لانه عندي
مرتاح من المخاطر حق العميل هذا لكن متى
اروح الكفاله لما اكون عندي شك في نجاح
هذا العميل لكن بنفس الوقت ودي ادعمه
متفائل ان شاء الله بينجح وبدعمه يمشي
موضوع السند لامر والضمانات شوف السنه دي
امر يعطيك جديه الامير يعني انت حاط قلبك
وروحك في المشروع هذا ولا بجرب
قفل الشركه وخل الباب بالفلوس
افهمها على المدير الشركه المدير بس في
شركه مستثمرين اموالهم انا حطيت فلوسي
معهم في الفريق التنفيذي في مدير يدير ليش
يطلب من كل الشركات
في حالات يطلب من كل الشركات وفي حالات
يطلب من الشريك المديرتي في الشركه هذه
لكن نشوف لا تنسى برضه اني انا لما قلت لك
كان راسمالي 30 مليار وحجم اصولي 360 370
مليار وين الفرق هذه
السنه
فموم المنطقه يعني اتوسع في اقراض عادي
المخاطر ويصير عندي وشفناها امانه انه
وجود السند امر يعطيك جديه اكثر همم شخص
واحنا بندعمها اعتراض السنه دي امر اخر
حاجه يصل لها البنك دائما تشتغل مع العميل
في ريسك
وحالات كثيره والله الحمد لله ويمكن في
خلال ازمه كرونه في 2020 قصه نجاح سواء
امانه يعني نفتخر فيها على مستوى البلد
انه كيف وزاره الماليه والبنك المركزي
والقطاع المصرفي كيف دعم نشاط المنشات
الصغير متوسطه انه يتعدى الازمه هذه بدون
الحمد لله سيستمتك اكثر بنك في اقراض
المنشات المتوسطه اهي من 360 مليار كم
منها للمشاهات همم اتاكد لك من الرقم لكن
احنا اذا ماني غلطان عندنا حوالي تقريبا
تقريبا
نسبه هذه وهل يحطوا نسبه التعثر في
المنشئه
كلها اعلى
لكنه همم زي ما قلت لك ال- ال- اللي قاعد
يصير في تنظيم البيئه البيئه كامله حق ال
ال المنشات الصغيره متوسطه قاعد يقلل
النسبه هذه الحمد لله والان تشوف المنافسه
بين البنوك على على القطاع هذا قاعد يزيد
بشكل كبير بسبب الحوافذ الكفاله بسبب
الحوافذ مو كل شيء يعني لما تتكلم عن
وزاره العمل وكيف تسهل اجراءات حق السعوده
وخلافه لشركات الصغيره متوصل لما اتكلم عن
هيئه الزكاه والدخل والجمارك وكيف قاعد
تدعم القطاع هذا لما تتكلم عن وزاره
التجاره ومنشات وتفهم فكل المنظومه
والصناعه مثلا الان عندهم حوافز معينه لما
تنظر كل هذا الدعم الحكومي اللي جاي نسب
النجاح تصير اعلى
فبالتالي نسبه الديفورت تصير اقل فبالتالي
يصير قطاع هذا مغري زي ما احنا نتنافس على
الشركات الكبيره بس نتنافس على الاخر نقطه
في موضوع كفاله همم احد الاصدقاء ارسل
تجربته الشخصيه يقول انا اخذت تسهيلات همم
مدعومه بكفاله من بنك الرياض وقعونا احنا
الشركاء يعني خلينا مثلا مليون ريال ههه
يقول خدنا مليو ريال اه
لنفترض انهم خمسه شركاء مقسمين بالتساوي
عشان بس نبسطها 20% كل واحد منهم يقول كل
واحد مننا وقعوه سند لامر ما هو بحجم حصته
الرياض عنده ضمان 80% من الكفاله وعنده
ضمان خمسه مليون ريال من الشركه على على
قرار خزان مليون
ما راح احصل من كل واحد منهم لكن هي زي ما
قلت لك هي تحمل البنك بس الرعب انا انا
حاط راسنا في الشركه اقل من هذا عشان
بياخذ قرض مليون مثل 20% اصير سند لامر
بالمليون هذه مرعبه يعني هذه حجره على
الاقل خذ خذ
في الشارع
في طلب الضمانات هو حجم المخاطر انا متاكد
ان المشروع هذا المشروع هذه المخاطر اللي
ناخذ فيه
همم كفاله وناخذ فيه ضمانات الشرك كلهم
همم اداء غرم تشاركيه معناته انه مشروع
عالي المخاطر فخياري انني انا اقول له
يمكن اعتذر منك او ادعمك بالطريقه هذه
فهذا السبب لكنها في النهايه انا ما راح
حصل خمسه مليون من الجميع وهل يفرق معاكم
انه هذا المنشاه في هذا النوع المشاريع
استمرت تاخذ وتسد تاخذ وتسدد هذا يؤدي الى
اعتماد يعني اكيد انا عندي تصنيف احتمالي
من صفر الى 22%
الخبرات السابقه التعامل السابق نجاح
العميل هذا يعني زي ما بدك انا في عملاء
مثلا يتعامل مع البنت من اربعين خمسين سنه
والحمد لله واجهتنا اي مشاكل معهم هذا
الامير انا عارف وعارف ومرت ازمات بيني
وبينه وقفت معه وقفه
فبالتالي لا ما يطلب منه هي زي ما قلت لك
لما تكون علاقه جديده لما تكون همم مشروع
عادي المخاطر انا مسؤوليه
اا
[موسيقى]
فهذا في ما يخص موضوع المنشات في المتوسطه
نجي الموضوع اللي قاطعتك في موضوع صناديق
التنمويه او اللي هي قطاع برنامج جوده
الحياه اغلبها اللي هي السياحه الثقافه
وغيرها لا هي طبعا الصناديق همم في
العقاري هذا لحاله بسولف فيه بس ابغى
اسولف معك قطاعات الجديده تمام
يعني شوف احنا خلي بس ارجع لك نقطه احنا
لما اعلنت رؤيه المملكه 2030 في 2016
كانت متزامنه الحمد لله مع استراتيجيه
البنك الجديد اللي اشتغلنا عليها في 2017
فكان فيه يعني الايمنت كبيره ما بين
مستهدفات الرؤيا
وكيف احنا نركز عليها وناخذ نستخدمها في
استراتيجيه البنك لدرجه انكم الظاهر اول
جهه في القطاع الخاص كلها تسوي مكتب تحقيق
رؤيا صحيح صحيح كانت مكتب تحقيق رؤيه
موجود في القطاعات الحكوميه
واحنا قطاع خاص وقلنا احنا كلاعب اساسي في
همم في تحقيق مستهدفاتر رؤيه لازم يكون
عندنا برده مكتب لتحقيق الرؤيا مكتب تحقيق
الرؤيا هذا بدا كان مكتب صغير وكان الهدف
منه حللوا كل البرامج الرؤيه هذه وشوفوا
وين التقاطعات اللي القطاع المصرفي بكل
دور فيها ولازم نكون احنا مبادرين
الحمد لله بدينا في 2018 في انشاء المركز
هذا وكان فيه يعني حجم عمل كبير من خرائط
حتى اني كنت اراهن الشباب اللي اشتغلوا
والشابات الي اشتغلوا على المشروع هذا
عندهم خلفيه عن الرؤيه توازن يعدل رؤيه
نفسهم ايييي فا
وصلنا الى انه فعلا هذه القطاعات اللي
مستهدفه في رؤيه 20 30 وهذه المبادرات حق
القطاعات هذه وهذه ال ال ال الما بينك
حقتها ما بين القطاع المصرفي فبدانا احنا
في يعني مبادره كده ان احنا نتواصل مع
الجهات هذه ونقول تعال
صندوق التنميه السياحي انت ضربت المثال
صندوق التنميه السياحي
انتم عندكم مستهدفات معينه نتشارك حنا
معكم في هذه المستهدفات خلونا نتوقع مذكره
تفهم او اتفاقيه مش مذكره تمام حتى ترقى
لانه نصل الاتفاقيه بانه كيف نخدم القطاع
هذا بشكل تشاركي يعني من قصص النجاح وانت
ذكرت الصندوق التنميه السياحي واعتقد ان
من اجمل قصص النجاح بالنسبه لنا يمكن
بالنسبه لهم انه وصلنا لمرحله انه عندنا
مشتركه بيننا وبينهم انا اجيب فرص
استثماريه في القطاع السياحي واملها
مشاركه مع مع طبيعه الشراكه هي نفس نظام
كفاله لان هم يضمنون بخاطر معينه انواع
مختلفه عفوا هو ممكن يدعمك بيقول لك لا مش
مشروع هذا انت مولانا عليه اول مشروع هذا
المولى انا وانت بنسبه تشاركيه
في المشاريع الكبيره لكن في المشاريع
الصغيره والمتوسطه يعني وقعنا معهم
اتفاقتين اتفاقيه من المشاريع الكبيره
الكبرى ودعم المشاريع الصغيره والمتوسطه
المشاريع الصغيره متوسطه بيكون بدور كفاله
اللي تعال مو والمشاريها هذه في مجال
السياحه بكثير المشاريع السياحيه وهنضمن
لك اياه بالنسبه معينه تختلف برضه نسبه
الضمان حسب نسبه المخاطر
وفيه التمويل المشترك طبعا هم عندهم برضو
اليه الاستثمار انه يجي يستثمر في في
المشاريع السياحيه يدخل كمستثمر مع
المستثمر الاساسي واحنا الاول كم مشروع
المولته كثير يعني
اعتقد كم مرحله الاولى اذا ماني غلطان
حوالي ثمانيه مليار ريال
ومولنا يعني جزء كبير منها امانه يعني من
المشاريع الكبيره الي موناها مشروع في
المدينه المنوره طبعا هو شوف الصندوق عنده
اهداف استراتيجيه ايضا
اللي هو ابغى ادعم السياحه في جميع مناطق
المملكه وانت تعرف انه
المناطق الريسك بروفايل حق المناطق مختلفه
يعني تتكلم عن مشاريع في مدينه الرياض اقل
من الخاطر المخاطر من تبوح مشاريع في
مناطق جديده
فالحمد لله مونا معهم مشاريع كثيره
مولنا مشاريع بضمنهاهم واحنا تجينا ايميل
اسبوعي يجيني انا ويجي الرئيس صندوق
التنميه السياحي بالمستهدفات والانجازات
بشكل اسبوعيه
في صندوق الثقافي في الصندوق الثقافي اول
حبينا نسوي ابلكيشن للنجاح هذا في مجموعه
كبيره من الصناديق الصندوق الثقافي كم
احنا بنتكلم عن القطاعات جديده نفس الشيء
بحجم اصغر يمكن من القطاع الثقافي يمكن
همم
اللا اللي فيه يعني لزق الحجم الصغير
فبالتالي بدانا بمبالغ بسيطه حدود 50
مليون همم
مشاريع ولكن مستعدين توسع فيه ما شاء الله
الدعم برضه للقطاع الثقافي كبير الحمد لله
من اهم الصناديق او اهم المبادرات اللي
يعني شاهدنا فيها هذا تغير ملحوض موضوع
نسب التملك للمساكن صحيح مدعومه مدفوعه
بالقروض العقاريه من البنوك وليس من
الصندوق العقاري انا هنا ابغى افهم ايش
بالضبط اللي صار مش مساهمتكم في الموضوع
وعندنا طبعا بعدها اسئله كثيره في
هالموضوع تمام شوف هو ما في ما في شك انه
همم الاسكان كاجده من زمان وهي فيها يعني
من التحديات الكبيره كانت في البلد انه
كيف الناس فعلا تتمكن انها تتملك المسكن
والمسكن دائما هو هدف استراتيجي لكل رب
اسره
من مستهدفات الرؤيا موضوع تمكين المواطنين
من تملك السكن واعتقد اذا ننظر من 2016
الى اليوم من اكبر قصص النجاح في وجهه نظر
الشخصيه نجاح منظومه الاسكان بدعم ما في
شك انه بقياده وزاره الاسكان والصندوق
العقاري وبمشاركه القطاع المصرفي واللي
احنا الامانه هذه من الاشياء اللي انا
افخر فيها انه فعلا انقطاع المصرفي ساهم
بشكل كبير في نجاح منظومه الاسكان لما
نتكلم عن
ارقام وصلت الى 300,000 شخص عائله تتملك
منازلها في السنه هذا انجاز ما هو بسيط
جدا احنا كنا نتكلم عن 50 الف 60 الف سنه
نصل الى 300,000 في السنه هذا انجاز كبير
ويمكن في الانجاز دورنا كبير
سابقا كان الصندوق العقاري يقرض ويعطي 500
الف ريال وتعال 500 الف ريال ما تسوي شيء
واللي ياخذها ويشتري فيها ارض مني يبيع
الارض ما ما يتبلك مسكن امانه وكان وقائمه
الانتظار طويله جدا
برؤيه المملكه 2030 وبيدعم همم
معالي وزير الاسكان يعني اعتقد انه امانه
كانوا دور كبير جدا في انه ينهض بالمنظمه
هذه ويحول ويمكن هو ما شاء الله خلفيه
العقاريه خلفيه المصرفيه ايضا ساعدتهم
بشكل كبير انه يعرف وين التحديات فيه
ويروح يعني معالي وزير الاسكان كان يروح
اسامه يجلس مع تيم ال ال اللي فاقل من
المستوى المعالي المحافظ ويدخل معهم في
التفاصيل اللي تمكن القطاع الاسكان فالحمد
لله فكان في تعديل في همم بعض الرجاليشن
معينه تقديم ضمانات
في تحدي كبير
كانت تروح للتمويل العقاري وكانت يمكن
ثلاث بنوك اللي شغاله فيه والبنوك الثانيه
تماما المحكمه عندنا لكن ما اللي حصل في
2015 و2016
في حاجه اسمها اللون تبالي انت لما تيجي
تقترض عشان تتملك منزل قيمه المليون ريال
بعض مليون عشان تسهيل كان البنك اكثر شيء
يعطيك 70% 700,000 وانت تدبر ب 300,000
300,000 يتحدي كبير للي ما عنده يعني راس
مال يبدا فيه
اشتغلت وزاره الاسكان مع البنك المركزي
لايجاد اليه معينه انه نرفع النسبه هذه
الى 85 طيب البنك المركزي كان يقول طيب
هذا بيدخل البنوك في مخاطر عاليه وانت
لازم تنظر لمنظومه كامله يعني تتكلم عن
منظومه
بما فيها المطورين هل كان في مطورين اسكان
هذاك الوقت جيدين يعطيك اريحيه ولا لا
يعني مرتبطه مخاطر كثيره مختلفه عن اليوم
فكان في اتفاق معين انه نرفع النسبه هذه
من 70 الى 85 اليوم ارتفعت ترى الى 90
بحيث انه بنبسطها ونعكسها انه الدفعه
الاولى هي 10% بدل ما كان يدفع 300 الف
الحين بيدفع 100 الف ريال حلو وايضا
استحداث منتجات جديده اللي يقول لك اثنين
في واحد تعال انا اعطيك حتى ال 100,000
هذه اعطيك عليها قرض استهلاكي انا اعطيك
قرض تستخدم لتدفع فيه الدفعه المقدمه
وعندك 80 90% تاخذها قرض عقاري يمتد معك
همم الى 25 سنه او اكثر او اذا تقدر تسدد
في فتره اقل الله يقويك يعني على امل ان
شاء الله انه المواطن هذا يرتفع دخله
ويصير عنده ممكنات انه يدفع همم ايضا ال-
ال- الوزاره والصندوق العقاري حول
المخصصات هذه كانت 500,000 اللي انتظرونا
لا حولها تعال خذ قرض من البنك وانا ادعم
لك النسب الفوائد
فلما تشوف الكتالوج حق المنتجات حق
الصندوق العقاري والبرامج الاسكان تلقاها
منتجات كثيره تناسب شرائح مختلفه من
المواطنين اللي يبغى شقه موجود برنامج
اللي يبغى ارض يقول لك انا ابغى
قرض موجود اللي يبغى بيت جاهز وحدات جاهز
موجود منتج فتنوعت المنتجات وتنوعت الدعم
وصاروا الناس يعني انا بدل ما انتظر 15
سنه او 10 سنوات عشان يجيء تغيير انه صارت
صندوق العقاري يدعم الفوائد اللي انتم
بتاخذونها من نبدا من المواطن جزء منها
الفوائد فبالتالي اكثر
برامج يعني منور كان يقول لك
بيت بيت جاهز امولك لكن الخريطه
لاني انا ما اثق مثلا في المطور انا ما
اعرف من المطور ما كان في مطورين في البلد
بحجم الزخم المطورين هذا كان في عمل كبير
جباره في موضوع البيع الخارقه كان في تخوف
مننا حكي قطاع مصرفي في البدايه طيب بيع
الخارطه اوكي جميل جميل
مئات الوحدات السكنيه الحمد لله السنوات
الماضيه عرفنا من المتميزين من اللي نجح
في التطوير فانا الان يمكن احنا في بنك
الرياض وقعنا للعام الماضي مع 17 مطور ان
احنا السعوديه
الان كبيره فبالتالي اقدر ابيعك همم امنحك
قرض عفوا على البيع الخارقه وهذا يساعدك
انت في في
ايضا ثلاث لا ننسى انه الجوانب التنظيميه
كلها جانب القضاء تحسن بشكل كبير يعني همم
كل قطاع ما يخلو من ال ال الاشخاص اللي
بيحاول محدد تحسن في القضاء له علاقه
بتملك مساكن همم التنفيذ التنفيذ تحسن
بشكل كبير طب احنا ما نصل هذه الا في
حالات نادره جدا وامانه يعني لما تصل
لمرحله التنفيذ على المنازل همم لاشخاص
تدبر فلوس
لكنه سابقا كان يستغل انه القضاء بطيء
والقضاء ياخذ وقت طويل والتنفيذ اجراءات
وكان ارتباط تطور بشكل
هناك هنقول نظام رهن العقاري ايضا انا
بتكلم في الموضوع كان نظام الرهن العقاري
صار ممتاز ارهان العقار هذا خلاص مضمون له
بنك سابقا يبيع العقار وانت ما يعني فكانت
صكوك تحفظ عندك في خزنه عشان ما يبيعها
صح
فتغيرت المنظومه كامل
بطريقه مباشره او غير مباشره
نمو كم همم نسبه
المحفظه العقاريه من 360 مليار حقكم يمكن
حوالي تمثل 18% 18 كم 2016 ده كانت اقل
بكثير اقل بكثير كانت يعني تتذكر لا والله
ما عندي تصور امانه
يعني انا انا اعتقد انه بنك الرياض كامل
البنوك المتوسعه في التمويل العقاري
ف- همم يمكنها كانت قريبه من خمسه سته
همم نسبه التمويل
العقاريات المجتمعين والمشاهدين في بالهم
مجموعه اسئله بلبس قبعاتهم عليك يتكلم عن
اكثر مشكله نتيجه عن هذا الحل المهم اللي
يساعد الناس بس خلقه مشاكل رقم واحد موضوع
تضخم الاسعار كثير
همم الارتفاع الكبير في اسعار الاراضي
واسعار الوحدات سكنيه
للاقراض الهائل
من البنوك هذه المشكله الاولى والمشكله
الثانيه موضوع
الشرائيه في ملاحظه لان القوه الشرائيه
على السلع الاستهلاكيه على
وهذا تقاس بعده مؤشرات سواء نتائج الاعمال
الريتيل ولا حتى الفاته التي تتورد
الحكومه هذه في انخفاض والبعض يعزوها ان
الناس مربطين بقروض اخذت جلد دخلهم فهذا
المشكلتين كيف تتعلق عليها كاثار للي
سويته شوف انا انا بحكي لك انا شفت او
تحول صار كبير من يمكن 2015 الى اليوم على
ال ال الاقتراض حسب الاقتراض الافراد
اعتقد انه اللي حصل بالعكس يعني اعتقد انه
شيء صحي انه الناس تتحول من اقراض
الاستهلاكي الى الاقراض المدعوم باصل او
الاقراب الاستثماري
انا اخذ قرض مليون ريال واصرفها على على
اجازه وعلى اشياء استهلاكيه تروح مني
تنتهي للمليون ريال واقعد اسدد في المليون
وانا ما عندي مشير مقابلها الاقراض
العقاري بالعكس شيء جميل جدا انه امانه
المبلغ هذا راح مقابل اصل اصل استثماري
باذن الله انه قاعد ترتفع قيمته والاشترى
في 2015 او 2016 عقاروا الان يمكننا ذبل
في سعره بيته
فتحول الاقراض الاستهلاكي الى اقراض عقاري
اعتقد انه صحي لانه زي ما قلت لك هدف
التملك هدف استراتيجي عند ربه انه يكون
عنده بيت يملك وهذا باقي له الابناء ان
شاء الله هذا صحيح اثر على القوه الشرائيه
لكن
خلينا نضرب مثال لشخص راتبه 10,000 ريال
همم همم اذا ما عنده اي التزامات عنده
10,000 ريال يصرفها بالكامل اذا انت قاعد
تصرف فلوسك انا امسكها لك في جزئيه في قرض
اا يروح منه سداد معين لكن بدايه بتمتلك
اصل اساسي بالنسبه لك فهذا احسن ما تصرف
في راتبك في وترى عندنا عادات استهلاكيه
كانت يعني همم يعني انت راتبك 10,000 تجيء
نهايه الشهر ما بقى منه شيء
ما تغير شيء
نهايه الشهر ما بقى منه شيء لكن انت دفعت
40% مقابل القرض العقاري مقابل البيت انت
قاعد تملكه فالناس كانت تصرف وتروح فلوسها
مقابل لا شيء الان تصرف وباقي لك اصل ان
شاء الله من وجهه نظرك همم وان كنت يعني
لست محايده بس من وجهه نظرك ترى بانه لانه
في اليوم موجه او صوت يقول لا تربط نفسك
بارض 20 سنه ياخذ نصف دخلك ولا ياخذ ثلثين
دخلك لا ترهن مستقبلك للبنوك هذا النوع من
وجهه نظري تطرح انت شلون تعلق عليها
كثر من كبار المستثمرين
انظرها بالنظر هذه دام الاستثمار في
العقار استثمار جيد انت قاعد تستثمر في في
منزل لك والابناءك فما هو يعني ما هو
خساره انت فلوسك حتروح ايجار
يا اخي اصرفها مقابل سداد مديونيه
المشكله الثانيه موضوع تضخم الاسعار هل
انتم اللي ساهم انا اعتقد انه تضخم
الاسعار فيهم جدا اول شيء يمكن لما ننظر
للرياض مدينه الرياض ك همم اكبر مدينه
فيها المشكله الحقيقيه
المشاريع الكبيره اللي قاعده تصير في
الرياض الزخم اللي قاعد يصير في الرياض
التوجه من الرياض تكون مدينه وعاصمه
اقتصاديه كبيره في المنطقه
والتوقعات اللي لعدد سكان مدينه الرياض في
المستهدفات الرؤيا هذا ما في شك انه هو
وعرضه طلب لما تقول والله الرياض تصل الى
15 مليون واحنا سبعه ثمانيه مليون يوم
تتكلم عن الدبل الدبل هذا من وين بيسكنون
فبالتالي هذا طبيعي انه يؤدي الى
تضخم الاسعار بالاضافه انه زي ما ذكرت في
الموضوع سواء النزع او الاماكن اللي اوقف
الافراغ فيها لمشاريع حكوميه كبيره قاعده
تتنظفه فبالتالي انت لما يقل المعروض
والطلب عالي فبالتالي طبيعي معادله
اقتصاديه لاسعار تزيد لما تتكلم عن مدخلات
البناء ايضا مع الانفليشن او تضخم اللي
حاصل مواد البناء ارتفعت تكلفه البناء
ارتفعت همم الانترستريت همم لما ترتفع
ايضا حتى ترتفع تكلفه الممول العقاري
المطور العقاري عفوا اللي هو يبني اللي
كان يقترض بنسبه معينه وارتفع نسبه بشكل
كبير لانه الاحداث العالميه مؤثره علينا
فبالتالي صارت تكلفه عاليه والسؤال المهم
هنا
الفتى الجايه يعني الخمس سنوات الجايه كيف
ترى المشهد في موضوع القضاء العقاري هذا
السؤال ينتظر اجابته عده اطراف كل واحد
ينتظر من زاويه مختلف فالمواطن يمكن ينتظر
يقول هل برامج دعم الاقرار هتستمر هل لي
فرص فيها
المطور بيعرف هذا الطلب بيستمر عشان يطول
واللي بتهددون وفي اطراف ثالث تقول اتمنى
يوقفون عشان يضيح العقار عشان يصير
الاسعار فالكل ينتظرها الاجابه خمس سنوات
اللي جايه هنتكلم احنا على استمرار النمو
ثبات ولا تراجع للقروض انا انا بارجع لك
للعرض والطلب احنا في اذا نظرت الى
التركيب الديموغرافيه حق المملكه احنا
مجتمع صغير في السن
فبالتالي كل سنه
قاعد يجونك من الشباب المستحقين للدعم
الحكومي
بقرابه 100,000 90 الى 100,000 على مستوى
المملكه على مستوى المملكه
مواطن مواطنه مستحقين للدعم يدخلون
الى جبلتي حق الدعم الحكومي هذه تضمن لك
طلب بشكل كبير
في السنوات القادمه
يزيد في السنوات القادمه لا تتكلم عن
الاشخاص اللي وصلوا لمتوسط ال 20 في
اعمارهم هذول هم اللي يبدا يفكر الان في
متوسط الجينات الى الى 30 يفكر في التملك
هذولي شريحه كبيره جدا واللي جايينك في
الباين لاين عددهم كبير فبالتالي هذا يعطي
طمانينه انه طلب موجود عشان بس المطورين
اطلب موجود
التملك لا يزال هدف وهاجس رئيسي للمواطن
فبالتالي
والقطاع المصرفي عنده الاريحيه انه يدعم
القطاع هذا وفي الحمد لله
بتقللون او اطرحك بشكل اخر شفت 18% تقريبا
عشان ما حط عليك مسؤوليه الرقم اللي هي
تمثل من اجمالي
محفظتكم اوصلكم هل لكم سقف تقول اذا وصلنا
السقف منا متعدين لا شوف انت في في مخاطر
يعني كسقف مخاطر موجود كل البنك
العقاريه يمكن يعني تصل الى 23% لكن كل كل
بنك يختلف طبعا
مبني على الرزق حقته همم احنا كل سنه
نراجع الثقافه
بناء على المتغيرات اللي حصل في السوق
الحمد لله شيء جميل في في المملكه
وبقياده رؤيه 2030 واللي قاعد يصير فيها
انه في منافسه ما بين الدعم
السياحه دعم الصناعه دعم الترفيه دعم
الرياضه دعم المنظومه الاسكان
فانت كبنك تقول لي والله هذه قطاعات انا
مطلوب مني ادعمها كلها فكيف اوزع ال ال
السيور اللي عندي لدعم وتوجيهها للقطاعات
هذه ولا تنسى برضو الطاقه المتجدده
والمشاريع الكبيره اساسا ومشاريع الصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه الجيجا بروجيكت هذه
برضه لها نصيب من حصه التموين فبالتالي
انا كيف فوازن ما بين مخاطري ودوري كادعم
اقتصادي في نجاح كل المبادرات هذه حق
الرؤيه فبالتالي هيكون همم الاسكان له
نصيب هيكون ان شاء الله السياحي نصيب
الصناعه الرياضه الترفيه وباقي قطاعات ال-
المستهدفه في الرؤيا فااه يعني ان شاء
الله باذن الله
نسب الفوائد
والتضخم اثر على زي ال ال القدره
المواطن انه يتملك صارت الاسعار مرتفعه ما
في شك انه نحن في اجتماعات متواصله مع
وزاره الاسكان والصندوق العقاري نجد حلول
لها عشان ما يقف في الزخم حق التملك هذا
نبغى المواطنين يتملكون ان شاء الله
فبالتالي ان شاء الله نجد حلول فالموزاره
تتكلم عن عن كثير من البرامج الجديده ان
شاء الله اللي يعني همم ومشاريع ضخمه ايضا
في همم في المدن الكبيره اللي حصل فيها
تضخم العالي
تشرب مويه وقهوه لانه الملف الجاي يعني
همم
قد يخرجكم من السوق همم
السعوديه همم
اشتراكه مع شركه اس بي سي همم اجمالي
الاقراض او مؤثر قيمه الجولات الاستثماريه
اللي صارت في الشركات الناشئه السعوديه
العام الماضي رقم تاريخ يقارب الملياردو
دولار
اعلى قطاع منها يعني وش تتوقعه سنتك كان
حدود 25% من هذا الاستثمار رايح لقطاع
الفندق اييه
اشرح لي كيف شعورك وكيف نظرتكم للحراك
اللي صاير في قطاع التقنيه الماليه وهل هو
مهدد ولا مكمل اللي عملكم طيب رد الاول
حنا البنك ويعرف ينتك احنا فاناش
تكنولوجيا كامري
اعتماد شبه كلي انا اليوم لو لا قدر الله
صارت عندي وصارت في جده مثلا لما اجت
الامطار الفتره الاخيره
لمده نص ساعه هذه كارثه كارثه كارثه كبيره
بعد مو كارثه صغيره
البنك اللي بيستطيع ان يكون عنده المرونه
عشان ينافس يكون البنك الربحان فانت لازم
تشتغل على على المرونه
فعلا تقدر تنافس الانترنت بيفكر مختلف
وبي- وبسرعه اتخاذ قرارات مضطر اني همم
اتحرر من برقيه او الاجراءات عمل الشركات
الكبرى ويكون القدره ان يتحرك بخفه عشان
انافس هذه هذه الاولى الشيء الثاني عنده
هو ادفانتج في الكوست او ال ال ال الفنتك
لكن انا في نفس الوقت عندي ادفانتج في
الكوست فوندينج لقطاعات معينه في نشاطي
همم
تمكني اني همم شريحه معينه قد تصعب فيها
المنافسه لكن انت سالت سؤال جميله انت هل
تراهمسك او او مكمل احنا سياستنا في البنك
ان احنا لازم نعرف شو الي حاصل في في
الفنتك وفي نفس الوقت انا عندي برامج دعم
لهم بحيث اني اربطهم معي ادعمهم او اتشارك
معهم او اخذهم اتفاقيه اكسكلوس انه ما
يشتغل معي او انه استحوذ عليهم
فانا انظرهم بكلنا انظرهم كمنافس وانظر
لهم كشريك فرصه استثماريه جيده
كلها
الحالات
بدون ذكر اسماء في شركات استحوذنا عليها
في شركات دعمناها وصارت ما شاء الله
يونيكون يعني بعطيك اسم جديد من الشركات
اللي اول من دعمها بنك الرياض ونفخر
فترات مكناهم في السوق شاركناهم
دعمناهم ومكلناهم انهم يمنمون بتعاملاتهم
مع بنك الرياض اا ترا السيسي احنا من
البنوك السيسي في البدايه همم
ومستمرين حتى نتعامل معهم كشرك في مجالات
معينه همم ما تكثرون عليهم زي بعض البنوك
احنا نتعامل معهم
ونحاول نافس يعني
وليد بالعكس يعني احنا عندنا برضو
من الاشياء اللي عمرك ما هتقدر توصل
لشريحه الي وصلهم السي سي بي ونظراهم
للصغار جدا جدا
خليني اعطيك كلامك صحيح الشريحه هذه اول
شيء شريحه كبيره جدا وشريحه هتكون في وجهه
نظري هي الايريا وفي تارجت بالنسبه
للفنتكس بالنسبه للنيو لي كامرز
وبالنسبه اللي زي الاس تي سي والمحافظ
الالكترونيه همم لكن تبقى الشريحه هذه
شريحه كبيره سواء المايكرو في الافراد
المايكرولينغ في الافراد اول الميكرو
اسيميس المايكرو بزنس برده شريحه كبيره
جدا من رواد الاعمال اللي بنكبر
ماما
شريحه كبيره جدا احنا في بنك الرياض
مهتمين فيها وهمم يعني
بعض المنتجات اللي قد تكون يعني
مملوكه لبنك الرياض لكن ما هي تحت مظله
بنك الرياض منتجات مستقله هتطلع ان شاء
الله باذن الله في المراحل الاخيره من
الحصول على الموافقات النهائيه فيها
التقنيه انتم رياض في هذا الصندوق
في رياض تقنيه فندم هذا الصندوق استثماري
عند الرياض الماليه هذا قديم من اوائل من
اوائل الصناديق اللي دخلت في البي سي او
في البنشر كابيتال هذا الصندوق طبعا يدار
من قبل الرياضي لكن مستثمرين
العاديه
احنا عندنا صندوق اخر اسمه رياض فانت
تكفوند هذه 100 مليون هذا المئه مليون
صندوق 200 مليون هو حجمه استثمر منه 100
مليون هذا
قلت لك عندي امثله في مشاركات شاركنا في
في اكثر من من يعني من من الفنتكس هذول
فرص ترابط همم
دخلنا معهم كشركاء واللي دعمهم ونستفيد
برضو احنا من شاركتنا معهم
هذا هذا صندوق استثماري للفنتكم
بسنتها من وين جاءت من رياض الخليليه
احنا حطينا 100 مليون 200 مليون من
الخزينه
همم تتجه لها لكن المجره في بسمه ان هي
وهذه نعتقد انها
يمكن ننظر لها بمنظور رسيرشن دي فالف منت
اكثر مما هي استثماري فا بحاجه 100 مليون
على على ميزانيه بنك حجمهم كبير بصراحه
ابو خالد لما نقول
يعني الخطر الخطر يعني
الاكثر ارتفاعا هل هو من البنوك الرقميه
اللي بدات تطلع وفعلا صدر تراخيص ثلاث
بنوته رقميه في السعوديه او من شركات
الفنتك بالنسبه لكم مين يقلق لكم اكثر
امانه اكثر شيء يقلقك نفسك
اذا ما قدرت اطول نفسك انت هتخسر جو الفيل
البان كل ما اجوا فانت لازم تكون مواكب يا
تتغير
او نقدم المشهد الى 20 30 اليوم
ايش دور البنوك يعني في ناس تتخيل البنوك
حتصير مجرد بك انت عباره فيها اموال ضخمه
حصلت عليها بطريقه ارخص
[موسيقى]
المقدمين الخدمات هي شركات تقنيه وفي نفس
الوقت
تختفي ولا
ينزل بشكل كبير مو متوقع في القريب العهد
ولا حتى في وقت المتوسط لان البنوك اصلا
زي ما قلت لك قاعده تتغير بشكل
شارع بشكل كبير جدا قاعد تستثمر في الفنتج
قاعد تنشئ فنتك اساسا مكمله عملها وقاعده
تتحول الى الى بنوك رقميه بشكل كبير يعني
خدمات اللي قاعد يقدمها البنوك في
السعوديه
90% ترى همم
دي جي سايز بالكامل يعني اشياء بسيطه
بتتطلب انه انه العميل يجيء الفرع وقاعده
تتحسن يعني قاعده حتى لو قلت لك انه همم
الامور
المتاخره هذه اللي باقي عفوا هتتعالج في
القريب العاجل يمكن تكون بها فيها ربط
الكتروني همم مع جهات اخرى خارج ثالث لكن
انا في 20 30 بتقدر تسوي كل شيء في وجهه
نظري
عن طريق القنوات
عندي في ال 19 18 سنه الماضيه عندي تراك
ريكورد وديت كنز اقدر احوله تسويقيا بشكل
رائع جدا فبالتالي لما يجي المقترض مني
اللهم يدخل على المنصه الرقميه حق التمويل
المنشات الصغيره متوسطه وتحليل اساسا
ادفانس انا لا تكسي يحلل لك وضعه الائتمان
يقول له موافقه عليك المبلغ الثاني فك
ينزل مبلغ في حسابك يعني هذا التوجه
كيف الديجيتال بنك
هيكون لها نصيب ما في شك ااا اللاعبين
دخلوا كلهم لاعبين قويين ما هو ما هم صغار
وحيدخلوا في بدايه على في تصور انا على ال
على ال ال المايكرولاندينج والمايكرو
اسميز وتستحوذ على حصه
جيده من السوق هذا البنوك هتنافس هتبقى
منافستها كبيره على على قطاع الاعمال
الكبير ولكن هتدخل منافس ايضا قوي في في
الشرائح الاقل
الفانتكس هيكون فيها همم تعاون شوف مع
الاوبن بان كينج وال همم نتكلم في البدايه
قلت لكن في اربع محاور الخامس
هذا التوجه في البنوك ان يكون بدايه يكون
عندك محور خامس هو الفنتك بانكي انه كيف
تعاملك مع الفنتكس كيف انت تكون منصه
تربطهم فيك بحيث انهم محتاجينك بشكل كبير
في المرحله الحاليه
وبالتالي انت تدعمهم وفي نفس الوقت تقدم
لهم الخدمات وتبيع عليهم يعني هم عملاء لك
الفيديو عندك مع الوقت وياكل من حصه
الادارات الثانيه والقطاعات الثانيه في
البنك لما يصير هذا الفيوتشر بانكن في 20
30 نظر لك انت تبغى تشوف هو دائما في 20
30 لا نرجع همم 23 خلينا هناك شوي من من
المستهدفات برنامج انه نزيد
المعاملات الماليه غير النقديه هذه كانت
مجرد 18% وقت
وصلنا اخر احصاء 57% متجوزين همم
340 صرع اللي عندكم همم
22 صرافه اللي عندكم
كم تتوقع يصير عددها في 20 30 ابي افرق
بين ال 8 المكائن الصراف وبين الفروع من
عندنا استراتيجيه مختلفه فيها في البنك
وهذه كلها مبنيه على على حقائق وعلى
توقعات مستقبليه ما في شك انه ازمه كرونه
عززت التعاملات الغير نقديه بشكل كبير جدا
حتى اللي كان عنده تخوف من انه يستخدم
القنوات الرقم
وبدا يستخدمها فبالتالي الارقام اللي
ذكرتها كانت فيها تزايد بشكل كبير احنا
لمسناها بشكل كبير في موضوع النقد
الصرافات غالبا يستخدم للعمليات السحب
لانه تسديد الفواتير او سابقه انكتابات
اللي كانت تتم عن طريق الصراف كل الان
سهله بشكل كبير عن طريق الموبايل
الامريكيشن ولا عن طريق الواتساب فبالتالي
بقيت الصرافات تقدم خدمه الايداع والسحب
النقدي ومع انخفاض الحاجه للنقد او
التعاملات النقديه لما انا انظر لل 2017 و
2018 و2019 قبل ال ال الكبد واشوف اداء
مكائن الصراف الالفين وشويه اللي ذكرتها
وكم منها الربحان وكم منها الخسران اجد
عندي 30 ماكينه خسرانه وكنا نقول يلا
الخسرانه لوكيشن انقلها لان المكان سيء
تخسر بعض الثانيه اسف
بشكل سريع تشرح لي اياها
اوكي لكن انت في تعاملاتك لما يجي عميل
بنك اخر يستخدم بطاقه
انا واحده القنوات اللي هنحسبها ربحيه
وخساره كانت معظم المكان الصراف هذه رابحه
اليوم معظمها خسرانه ايه ما عاد في احد
يستخدمها في معاملات التسديد معاملات اللي
كانت لهذا بسببين بسبب تقدم الخدمات
الالكترونيه عن طريق التطبيق عن طريق
الموقع والسبب الثاني رياحيه الناس
باستخدام القنوات التقنيه والسداد يعني
ايضا بعد
الازمه في 20 20 ترا حجم النمو في قطاع
البوينت في السيز او همم نقاط البيع انما
بشكل كبير فبالطبيعي لما ينمو النقاط
البيع يؤثر على همم المكائن الصراف
وتعاملات النقديه الكاش فاليوم انا
استراتيجي في في مكان الصراف انه قدامه
لانه ما في حاجه لها مو لانه والعدم همم
عدم الحاجه لها في قله استخدامها
فبالتالي في 22 هذه كم متوقعه في 20 30
نصها ربعها والله انا اتوقع انها ربع
هيكون يعني يمكن اكثر من الحاجه اوكي لانه
خلاص
الفروع
قصتها مختلفه شويه يعني الفروع ومن احاول
تكون شفاف مو دبلوماسي عشان ما تخوف الناس
واش واقع الفروع لا لا انا بالعكس انا
احنا سياستنا في بنك الرياض احنا في
الفروع قاعده
السبب الحقيقي لانخفاض اعداد الفروع ما هو
سبب حقيقي ما هو سبب انخفاض في اعداد
الفروع هي سببها الدمج الفروع النسائيه مع
الفروع الرجاليه البنوك سابقا كان عندها
فروع نسائيه وكان عندها فروع رجاليه الفرع
النسائي اللي هو يكون الدور الثاني من
الفرق يحسب فرع مستقل له مديره فرع ومديره
سوسراف وخدمه عملاء ولك الدور الارضي كان
يعتبر فرع ثاني فرع رجالي فلما بدانا ندمج
الفروع هذه ونقدم الخدمات للجنسين من
الفرع الواحد وهذا الزملاء الزميلات في
الفروع
انخفض عدد الفروع لكن هي حقيقه ما انخفض
هذه الفروع هي انخفض عدد الرخص لانه ده
مجلس الفروع
ما قفلت ولا انا قاعد ازود فروع اساسا
احنا قاعدين نزوج فروخ
انا يمكن اني قفلت فروع لكن اعتبرها اقفال
من ناحيه الاوبتيمايزيشن انا اجي اشوف
والله في الرياض عندي ثلاث فروع في منطقه
واحده في وسط الرياض سابقا في البطحاء
عندي مثلا فروع ولا في همم مناطق اخرى
عندي ثلاث فروع قريبه من بعض انا ممكن
اقفل واحد وافتح في شمال الرياض في التوجه
العمراني الجديد في الرياض لكن انا خطتي
في في في البنك الرياض لانه احنا نتوسع
وانا اعرف ان هذه خطه البنوك الاخرى
الكبيره في مصرفيه الافراد انها تتوسع
تتوسع بشكل مختلف تتوسع مسمار الفرع اللي
كان ضخم تشوفه كانه ما شاء الله قصر
هذه
اماكن
خدمه عملاء 12 واحد ومدير فرع نائب مدير
فرع ومساحه كبيره هذه ما عاد نحتاجها اهم
شيء انه يكون في كل الخدمات تقدم للعميل
اللي يجي فبالتالي انا بتوسع في اعداد لكن
في فروع سمارت برانشيس اللي هي اييي اصغر
حجما التيلر ما يحتاج انه يكون منطقه
الصراف اللي كان فيها سته اشخاص اليوم
اثنين وتلقاهم نص وقت قاعدين في الاربعين
تتوقع اكثر 30 باذن الله باذن الله هتكون
انا في وجهه نظري طبعا احنا راجعنا نشوف
التعاملات احنا مستثمرين في الفيزيكن
ومستثمرين في الديجيتال الديجيتال قاعده
تنمو لكن في نفس الوقت ال- ال- الفيزيكال
قاعده
وتختلف ما بين ترى مدينه ومدينه منطقه في
ناس بتحب تروح يمكن الزحمات في الرياض خلي
الناس تحجم عن ههه
فيها زخم كبير منطقه عسير نمو اييه منطقه
جازان نمو ايضا فيها مشاريع كبيره فتطلب
توسع وتنتظر بتربطها بالحراكل الديموغرافي
وزياده عدد السكان في المناطق فبالتالي
انت لازم تكون قريب منهم وتدعمهم وببلانا
نتكلم عن المستقبل وهذا اخر سؤال في
الجزئيه وش قرائتك لنوعيه الوظائف اللي
بتصير يعني في كثير وظائف في في الفرع
اليوم صار فيها احلال صار فيها تغيير
فالشباب اللي اليوم مقبولين على على على
على اختيار مجالات الحياه او على اختيار
تخصص او على التقديم على الوظائف ايش نوع
القطاعات اللي تعتقد انه هيكون عليها طلب
اكثر او المهارات او التخصصات بحيث تستفيد
احد يسمعوننا خليني يعني يمكن انا ماني
افضل واحد يقيم المستقبل لكنه بعطيك من
المنظور القطاع المصري ولو رجعت من 2019
الى اليوم احنا الاثنين ممكن ننظف فيه
بشكل كبير
البزر التكنولوجي
الاي تي الجنرالي
مهم جدا جدا لانه فيه مع التحول التقني
هذا قاعد يزيد الاهتمام بالامن المعلومات
والقوه الانظمه حق البنك في حمايه معلومات
المتعاملين
الديجيتال الديجيتال والبيانات هذه فيها
زخم في التوظيف ايضا بشكل كبير لانه يعني
توجه كبير ببعض
فهذه يعني
الجوانب التقنيه اللي يمكن استحولات على
اكبر جزء من توظيف في بنك الرياض يمكن
احنا نرى من من بدانا رحله التحول في بنك
الرياض من 2018 الى اليوم يمكن 22 ترا
اللي زاد عدد الموظفين استمرين الحمدلله
نمو وعدد الموظفين باقي زي ما هو في 2021
بدانا نتكلم عن الاستثمار بشكل كبير في
البنيه التحتيه حق الانستغرام
يعني همم الاشخاص اللي جربوا منصات بنك
الرياض ما يعتبرونها من افضل التجارب لا
التطبيق ولا الموقع شوف احنا الحمد لله
ال- ال- اليوم واليوم تحديدا كنا انتهينا
من الورشه عمل كبيره لتطوير تطبيق بنك
الرياض لانه المؤمنين انه انه الابلكيشن
تجربه مرضيه احنا لو تدري اليوم شو كنا
نتناقش فيه يمكن يمكن تضحك بس بقول لك
الهدف عندنا لما عرضوا علينا البنش
ماركينج وكان يتكلمون لك عن البنوك عالميه
انه هذا من افضل البنوك في تطبيق الموبايل
ابلكيشن وهذا في اوروبا من افضل البنوك
وهذا في العالم في الشرق الاوسط وهذا في
السعوديه
قلنا لهم انه احنا لما ننتهي من الابلكيشن
حقنا ابغى اي بنك في العالم يسوي البنج
مارك هذا يطلع فيه اسم بنك الرياض يقول
تطبيق بنك الرياض يعتبر من افضل التطبيقات
في في العالم متى يكتمل والله باذن الله
الاولى
والحمد لله يعني عندنا الخطه الواضحه باذن
الله ان احنا بنهايه السنه تطبيق جديد ان
شاء الله يكون ان شاء الله همم
سؤال همم
الفائده على قروض المواطنين اللي اليوم
كثير منهم يعني
شوف همم القروض النوعين القروض
الاستهلاكيه والقروض العقاريه همم القروض
الاستهلاكيه طبيعتها هي نسبه فائده ثابته
وقت المنح ثبتت مع معتز عليكم وباستهلاكيه
هذه القروض الشخصي لفظي القرض الشخصي اللي
هو 33% ااه للحد الخمس سنوات 60 قسط بما
يتجاوز 33% من راتب الشخص
ثابته القروض العقاريه تنقسم قسمين همم
مرابحه واجهاره الاجاره كانت يعمل فيها في
السابق اللي هي القروض المتغيره اللي اخذ
قرضه بطريقه الايجار اللي هي متغيره لما
ترتفع نسب الفائده يرتفع عليه القصه
لكن هذه يعني من تقريبا 2018
اذا ماني غلطان معظم البنوك تحولت الى
المرابحه لقصه ثابت فما راح يتغير عليك
والاخرين يعني لازم ان نتكلم
ما تمت عمليه الريف رايسي لكنه تاثيرها
مستقبلي ما في شك انه اي شخص الان بيقترض
بيقول لك
قاعد يدفعها ما راح يتغير عليه لانه يعتبر
انسان الي في عام 21 هذا انسان
اللي يبغى ياخذ فلوس مجاني يجي ياخذ في 21
22 تغيير الصوره شوي طبعا ما في شك انه
اليوم ايضا بحكم ارتفاع السايبر صارت في
اسئله كثيره على قراءتكم للمشهد يعني
الناس اللي بتعرف متى نهايه
اللي قاعده تصير اي همم في موضوع الفائده
ايش قراتك
بس احنا زي ما ذكرت في البدايه لان احنا
مرتبطين في الفدرالي وباللي قاعد يصير في
العالم زياده والله شوف انا اعطيك البست
انا لست انديكيشن وبتغيرت يعني حتى
الاسبوع الماضي يتغيرت كان الجميع يقول لك
انه فيه زياده اخيره في يناير ب 50 نقطه
ثم تستمر السنه كامله بدون اي زياده
وبننظر للربع الرابع ديسمبر نوفمبر احتمال
يبدا نزول
وكانت توقعون النزول هيكون سوفت على على
24 على 25 نزول حسب المعطيات الاقتصاديه
وظهرت بيانات اقتصاديه الاسبوع الماضي ما
كانت جيده فبالتالي الناس يتكلمون عن لا
رفعتين
رفعتين قد تصل الى واحد في المئه 50 و 75
مثلا
هذه
وان كانت قويه وبتزيد تكلفه الاقرار لكن
اتبعت حقتها ان يقول لك لا بس انت اذا
سويتها بيكون اللي يسمون السوفت لاندينج
خيار ما هو موجود انه هيكون فيه نزول
الحادث فلما يصير فيه
اقتصادي او انكماش اقتصادي فبالتالي هيكون
في تسارع في النزول يعني عشان ترجع
ما هو بشكل تباته على سنوات
يعني خلاص
اكثر
انا اتمنى الاولى
اتوقع الاولى
اعتقد انه ال ال
الاقتصاديات العالم تعلمت من الضربات اللي
اجت سواء في 2008
وحجم التقنيه والكمينيكيشن تحسن بشكل كبير
بحيث انه يساعد انه ضربات القويه هذه ان
شاء الله وفي السنه هذهين كلها تتوقع انه
من 24 يبدا ما في ثبات
لازم يكون نزول قوي او يكون نزول متوازن
همم اختلاف الان في سؤال مهم ابو خالد انا
ما حث على السؤال اللي بعد
يعني السؤال حق ازمه سيوله في البنوك كل
البنوك
فانا هسالك هل في ازمه سوري
ليش الناس قاعده تتطرح هذه السؤال في هذا
التوقيت
تنفي وجود ازمه السيوله في البنوك
يعني نظرنا الى رؤيه 20 30 الطموحه جدا
كان في تساؤل كبير جدا يقول لك طيب القطاع
المصرف السعودي ما راح يقدر يمول حجم
الطلب المتوقع عشان نحقق المستهدافات رؤيه
20 30 لانه عارفين انه الودائع وحجمها
وقدرتنا على الاقرار فكان هذا التحدي
موجود من 2016
مرحله فعلا انه في شورتج في السيوله في
البلد همم الرؤيا ايضا مبنيه على استثمار
اجنبي على تمويل خارجي على الدت عفوا همم
اصدار صكوك وسندات سواء وزاره الماليه او
حتى صندوق الاستثمارات العامه كعب مهم
عنده مشاريع المشاريع الكبيره هذه
صندوق الامارات العامه اعلن برنامج وحب
التمويل فبالتالي يعني هذه يغطي جزء كبير
من من المخاوف اللي كانت موجوده
من ناحيه تمويل المشاريع الكبيره هذه
امانه ايضا ارتفعت اسعار النفط في عام 20
22 ساعدت الحمد لله بشكل كبير في تعزيز
مداخيل الدوله فبالتالي ساعدت في تاجيل
مشكله انه احنا نقول مش مشكله تاجيل موضوع
انه السيوري يصير فيها تحدي كبير
طبعا ما يخفى على الجميع انه في عام 22
ويمكن في ثلاثه شهور او شهرين همم
وجون كان فيها فعلا في شحف السيوله بشكل
كبير وتسمعنا مع البنك المركزي البنك
المركزي يشكل اللجنه مع وزاره الماليه
وتدخلوا اللي معالجه الوضع هذا طبعا
السيوله موجوده وزاره الماليه عند السيول
البنك المركزي عند السيوله السيوله ما اجت
القطاع المصرفيه هذا كان بس انه كيف نضمن
انه همم السيوله بس اليوم في السنه هذه
اللي احنا نتكلم
هذا كبير تعرف انه في سور عاليه في البلد
لما يصير المبلغ هذا المودع في في الريبو
الموده في عفوا في البنك المركزي منخفض
يعني انا اتكلم عنه ما عندها فوائظ ما
عندها فوائد ما عندي فلوس احطها عندك اصلا
اوبر نايت
فهذا وصل في مطحن مراحل تقريبا الذي 8
مليار ريال هو كان يصل الى 70 80 100 فوق
ال 100 من كثر حجم السيوله الموجود فلما
ينزل الرقم هذا الجودن بكيشن انه فعلا فيه
شحب السيوله في البلد في هنا سؤال على
ايهما اكثر تاثيرا على السيطره على التضخم
السياسه الماليه او السياسه النقديه او
هذا السؤال اقتصادي
ونحتاج اذا كرما انت بسطتها الفرق بينهم
اللي ما يعرف شوف انا اعتقد انها همم
السياسه النقديه همم اهم
السياسه الماليه هي يعني عنده وزاره
الماليه السياسه النقديه عند عند البنك
المركزي السياسه الماليه تيجي تقول والله
يعطيك مثالي يمكن سهل تقول انا بادعم قطاع
معين
عشان انا بعزز نشاطه في البلد فبخفض عليه
ضرائب
تقول والله نشاط القطاع الصناعي او الامن
الغذائي كنت بفكر في الامن الغذائي لك
الصناعي خففنا عليها
في السنوات السابقه كان المستثمر الاجنبي
لما يجي السعوديه كان ياخذ تاكس هوليدي
يقعد عشر سنين عشر سنوات ما يفضل عليه
ضرائب
ابداليه انا بدعم ال همم النشاط الصناعي
في المملكه فبالتالي بجيب التقنيه والنهار
البلد واعطيهم عشر سنوات ما يدفع ضرائب
الماليه
اللي هي تتدخل في موضوع السيوله التضخم
اضخم سيوله في البلد ولا اسحب سيوله اربط
ال- ال- السايبر واللايبر اتابع كيف عشان
ما يكون فيه جاب بين
اللي هي تحركات البنك المركزي تحركات
البنك المركزي هي هي
اتوقع ان السياسه النقديه
على معدل
الاقتصاد هذا احنا شرحنا قبل شويه نشوف
بساطه يقصد عندنا شهيه واسعه على المشاريع
هائله كلها قاعدين نستخدم ممكن لا بس جزء
كبير منها قاعد استخدم سيوله البنوك
المحليه مو قاعدين نجيب تمويل من برا صحيح
بعطيك بس اجابتيني يمكن واحده مرتبطه
بالتمويل العقاري ايضا يمكن اللي حصل يمكن
ادى همم النمو الكبير في الاقراض انه
النوعيه المشاريع اللي قاعدين نشوفها في
المملكه الان سواء الجيجا بروجيكس اول شيء
هي كبيره حجمها ملياريه
وعمرها طويل حتى صالون كثير
جروس
المشاريع الحكوميه صحيح
في البلد لكن انا قبل شويه قلت لك انه
صندوق الاستماره العامه اعلن ايضا عن
برنامج في الدت او في الطرح ايضا صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه يعني من الجهات اللي
قادره على الاقتراض الدولي وسواوا اخذوا
قروض دوليه فبالتالي الصندوق قاعد يوازن
وله دور كبير انه في وزن ما بين ان اي
دونت كراون البرايفت سيكتور باني اخذ كل
قروض منهم لكن في نفس الوقت اقترض ما
احتاجه من السوق المحلي بما لا يزاحم
المقترضين الاخرين عندي وسائل اصدار
الصكوك والسندات بتوفر للسيوله كبيره
وعندي ايضا اقتراض الخارجي
السعوديه انها اغلقت همم سندات او صكوك ب
10 مليار دولار
لما تقول الحكومه السعوديه
ليش يحتاجون اكثر
انه السيوله موجوده
عندي متى ما احتجتها اوكي وعندهم طعم
مستهدفات انه نسبه الدين الى الى ال
الناتج المحلي بنسب معينه وما دام عندهم
روم في الاقتراض فانا ابني الكوشنز
والكباسته عندي من الان تحوطن لي اي
مشاريع قد احتاج اني يعني اتوسع فيها في
الفتره القصيره السابقه كثير الاجنبيه
فتحت فروع لهذا السعوديه
هل ستؤثر هذه على البنوك السعوديه يمكن
تطرقنا اليه الجزئيه همم يعني شوف انا
نحتاج لم ياكل اجنبيه امانه كقطع بنظرها
باستقلاليا انا بقول لك انا كقطاع مصرفي
وحجم الطلب وحجم المشاريع وحجم همم
المستهدفات الرؤيا نبغى بلوك تيجي نبغى
يعني نستفيد من همم من الوداع حتى لما كنا
في اجتماعاتنا مع البنوك الاجنبيه في
الاجتماعات السنويه لصندوق النقد الدولي
كنت اتكلم معهم منه لما تجينا مشاريع
كبيره هل انتم مستعدين تولونها مشاركه معي
انا زي ما قلت لك لو يجيني مشروع بمليارين
المشروع واحد بمليرين انا ودي اقرب مليار
واجيب معي شريك بنك اخر مليان واروح اتحول
لتوزيع مخاطر وتوزيع السيوله على دعم
مشاريع
تنمويه اخرى فبالتالي بالعكس يعني الحمد
لله لو كان ما في حراك اقتصادي بقول لك
ايه والله
والكيكه صغيره ما شاء الله الحمد لله
الحركه الاقتصادي رائع حجم ال- ال- ال-
الكيكه اللي تشارك فيها حجم كبير جدا
اللي قاعد يصير في البلد همم
سابقا كان بنك الرياض هو المسؤول عن
النشره اليوم صحيح
والله شوف الحين قاعد يتغير طريقه الحسبه
ااا
صحيح بنك الرياض كان هو المسؤول عن نشر
السايبر اعتقد انه لا لان ستداره عن طريق
البنك المركزي ااا
هذا يسال على موضوع الاندماج ليش فشل
الاندماجكم مع اهلي
اول شيء كلمه فشل
احتج عليها صحيح ولا ايش لم يتم لا لانه
احنا ما عندنا عشان نفشل
وانتهاء محادثات لا يعني فشل انت لما
اعلننا او لما اعلن البنكين انهم دخولهم
في محادثات اندماج هي اعلان عن النيه
لدراسه فرصه اندماج محتمله
احنا بكل جديه اخذناها جلسنا تقريبا اعلى
اعلان نزل في ديسمبر 2018 واعلان انتهاء
المحادثات نزل في ديسمبر 2019 السنه كامله
من العمل الجاد والحقيقي لتقييم انه
الفرصه الاندماج هذه هل تخدم مساهمين
البنكيين هل تخدم عملاء البنكين هل تخدم
القطاع المصرفيه هل تخدم كل الاستيك
هولدرز اللي متعاملين مع القطاع المصرفي
خلاصه النقاشات هذه بينت في تقريبا نوفمبر
اكتوبر نوفمبر انه ما اعتقد انها هي هي
المناسبه للبنكين لا تخدم مصلحه مثلا
المساهمين فبالتالي همم بالاتفاق ما بين
المكان
[موسيقى]
مواضيع استراتيجيه
تناقش على مستوى رؤساء المجالس في مجلس
الاداره البنك احنا اداره تنفيذيه ما ما
اجي اقول تعالوا خلينا ندمج منك ما هم
المنطقي انا اني اناقش المواضيع الاندماج
يعني اتركها للمجالس في هنا رساله من احد
زملائك في البنك يقول السلام عليكم اتمنى
لهذه النقطه ان تجد متسع في نقاشكم ولا
تستبعد ابشر
يقول الاستاذ طارق من الشخصيات الجميله
المتواضعه البنك الرياض وذكر صراحه الكلام
طيبه
وهذا كله على المستوى الخارجي اما
الداخليه سيكون اكثر تحديدا لطبيعه عملي
للاسف نعاني من غطرسه وتسلط الكثير من
المدراء مدراء المناطق والاقليم احنا في
قطاع الفروع مهمشين كادين كلب هذا المستوى
اهداف مستحيه تهديدات مستمره تقريبا
السنويه للاسف لا يوجد توزيع عادي في
السلم الاجور الوظيفي وكذلك مكافاه
الثانويه
تذهب المدراء ولا نحصل في النهايه الا على
الفتاه طويله
بالنسبه له هو ينقل هذا الشكوى باسم
الجميع يعني شوف لما اشتغلنا على برنامج
التحول لبنك الرياض كان الجزء الخاص
بالراس المال البشري هو مستحوذ على الجانب
الاكبر لانه عارفين انه اي مبادرات بنفذها
في بنك الرياض اذا ما عدلنا امورنا
احنا في فيزنس اذا ما اهتميت بالجانب
البشري ومكنتهم ودعمتهم وحفستهم لا تنجح
اي مبادل عندك انت تنجح فكان هذا محور
اهتمام بشكل كبير اللهم لك الحمد بدانا
وبدانا نقيسه بشكل دوري سنويا
طرف ثالث يجيء يقيس ما يسمى بالاردنيزيشن
بثانويه بناء على سيرفي كامله يعني يشارك
فيها العام الماضي شارك فيها 98% من
الموظفين البنك
وصلنا السنه هذه حوالي 11000 كومنت يعني
بتكلم عن 98 يشاركون في السرفيه حق 20 22
وتصلك نحن تقريبا حوالي
67000 موظف وتصلك 11000 كومنت هذه ايمان
من الزمل والزميلات انه هذه في السنوات
الماضيه من 2018 الى 2022 ان الكومنت هاي
تاخذ بجديه لما ننتهي من السريه هذه ناخذ
الكومنت هذه نحللها في مجموعات ونطلع
اداره تنفيذيه اوف سايد ميتنج يوم كامل
ندرسها ونحللها ونعرف وين المكان من قوه
كامل الضعف عندنا في البنك ونضع الخطط
اللي نعالجها ونضع الخطط اللي على المستوى
القطاعات ايضا
زملائنا في مسرحيه الافراد ما في شك انهم
من اهم الواجهات لبنك الرياض هذولي
السفراء انا اللي يواجهون العملاء لكن
يعني في تحدي في كل المنظمات تحدي انت جاي
من
ليجاسي كبير في الترانسفورميشن
يصير فيها هيك بس لكن متاكد انه كل شخص في
بنك الرياض له معزه وله اهتمام وصوته
مسموع يعني احنا في كل القنوات انا يعني
احرص جدا اني ازور قد ما اقدر فروعه في
بنك الرياض انا نزلت فرح حقل وزرت فرع
بالجرشي وعندي تاركه اني ازور كل فروع بنك
الرياض ما زرتك يمكن اكثر مدينه قصر ماهر
الفريق من الموارد البشريه وفريق الموارد
البشريه في 2021 بعد الازمه زار كل الفروع
وقال اعطونا ملاحظاتكم ملاحظاتهم تاكد
انها تدخل في اكشن في اثبات حق الاكشن
قد يكون يعني
في نفس الوقت انت في بزنس والمنافسه شرسه
ما بين البنوك وتحديده في مصرفيه الافراد
فبالتالي قد تضع مستهدفات قويه على بعض ال
ال ال ال الفروع بعض المناطق ايمانا منه
بقدره الزملاء وان شاء الله امكانياتهم
يحققون اهداف هذه فيمكن زميلنا يعني يعطي
اهداف يمكن ما تمكن يحققها كان فيها تحدي
كبير لكن تاكد انه يعني الزملاءنا في
الفروع صوتهم مسموع همم مدير مصرفيه همم
نائب الرئيس المسؤول عن المصرفيه الافراد
دوره انه يهتم فيهم ويشوفهم بشكل دوري
اصلا هو جاي من الفروع يعني فيعرف مشاكل
الفروع همومهم وما شاء الله عليه ما يعني
بشكل
جديد في المركز المالي ولا لسه ههه
بدانا العمل طبعا المبنى شويه يعني يحتاج
تهيئه قبل ما تدخل في الفتاوت فاحنا الان
في مرحله التهيئه همم باذن الله نتطلع ان
شاء الله انه خلينا نقول يعني لاني متفائل
ولا متشائم نقول منتصف 24 يعني يكون
الفريق الاول همم اول اول مجموعه داومت
هناك ان شاء الله ملك ولا استئجار
طارق رئيس لجنه الاعلام للبنوك نشوفهم
كثير عن الاحتيال وفي حالات ضخمه بصراحه
الكلام كثير على موضوع الاحتيال مؤخرا
صحيح واحد الزملاء في القطاع المصرفي يقول
لي انه تكلمت عالم الليارات يوميا همم
يكون في احتيال وتسترد بعضها وبعضها ما
يسترد لان وصلت
لنا بشكل موجز حجم المشكله
همم الاحتيال المالي هي مشكله عالميه ما
تختص فيها السعوديه او اي دوله ثانيه
الاحتلال المالي زاد بشكل كبير لما زادت
التعاملات التقنيه مش على مستوى القطاع
المصري فقط لما زادت التعاملات التقنيه
وصارت الناس تشتري اون لاين حتى المتاجر
الالكترونيه لما تحسنت الخدمات
الالكترونيه الحكوميه فساد فعلا
الاعتماد على جانب التقني الكبير جدا وهذا
المحتارين شافوا فرصه كبيره انه يدخلوا
يعني في النص
ويعني
يقوم بالعيبهم اللي للاسف تؤثر على همم
المتعاملين في القطاع المالي وغيره هو ما
في شك انه مشكله كبيره همم
مؤلمه جدا همم
التوعيه فيها مهمه جدا ويمكن يعني لجنه
الاعلام والتوعيه المصرفيه اللي انا راسها
للثلاث سنوات 21 22 23
قامت الحمد لله بحملات كبيره واعتبرها
عملات ناجحه جدا سوينا حمله تخليك حريص
العامل ماضي سوينا حمله لا يبيعونك في
السنه اللي قبله وكل حملات يعني وصلنا
الحمد لله فيها الى تفاعلات كبيره جدا على
على ارض الواقع وعلى عن طريق القنوات
المركزي بدا يشتغل على اجراءات همم
احترازيه كبيره اجراءات معينه قد ما تقلل
بشكل كبير من الاحتيال لكن قد تقلل من
نجاح المحتال وهذا الحمد لله اللي كان
فيها نجاح كبير يعني لما المحتال يكلمك
انا والله وانا جاي في الطريق جاتني رساله
يقول
تحديث حتى والله تحديث بطاقه ما يذاكر اسم
البنك كلم من الرقم الثاني ودقيت عليه
طبعا هندي
يعني يتكلم معك بلهجه الهاوش يبغى احدد
بطاقه ولا يبغى همم قفل حساب
فلما عرف اني فاهم قفل السماعه بوجهي
للاسف في ناس كثير تقع في فخ المحتال
ودائما بياناتنا ارقام التليفون اصلا
البنك اللي ذكر ليا في الرساله انا ما
عندي حساب فيه فهو يعني البنوك الكبيره في
مصرفيه الافراد معروفه فهو دائما يرمي
البنك الاول يقول ما عندك يحاول البنك
الثاني ثم يحاول البنك الثالث الثالث
يعني الارقام موجوده وما هو ارسل رساله
عشوائيه وهو يرسل مئات الرساله
وصار في تعاملات ابل بي في ايطاليا
شراء عن طريق ابل بي في ايطالي
ا استخدام بعض المواقع اللي ما هي مضمونه
وادخال بياناتك البنكيه فيها رقم بطاقه
وكذا في بعض المواقع هذه يقدر المحتال
يخترق المواقع هذه ويحصل على بيانات
البطاقه يحصل على رقم البطاقه يحصل على
اسمك على رقم جوالك لانك لما تشتري تحط كل
المعلومات هذه عنوانك كل شيء عنده شيء
الوحيد اللي ما يقدر يسويه اللي هو ما
ينفذ العمليه الا لما يصير في دبرها
حصل على المعلومات هذه عند الرقم الخلفي
حق البطاقه الخلفي هذا ثلاث ارقام
يحتاج الكود
واكلمك
في خلفيه انه نحن بنحدث ولا جايتك شحنه
وبيجيك لينك ادخل على الرابط وبجيك كود
عطني اياه لما تعطيه الكود هو حصل على كل
شيء يحتاجه اضاف بطاقتك في ابل بيت فعند
زي ما انت تستخدم بطاقه تروح تشتري فيها
من اي مكان في العالم ويسوي نفس الشيء
يشتري فيها
الاجراءات اللي عملنا عليها مع التوجيهات
البنك المركزي الحمد لله حددت بشكل كبير
جدا من نجاح المحتال لازلنا قاعدين نحارب
المحتالين بالتوعيه وباجراءات معينه يعني
كثير الحمد لله الحالات طبعا ارقام كثيره
حجم التعاملات الالكترونيه ضخم جدا وارقام
ضخمه والحمد لله رغم انه بس احنا 100
مليون تزعلنا جدا يعني ليش ياخذ ليش يسرق
من المواطن السعودي 100 مليون اخذها محتال
وغربيه
يعني شيء مؤلم
سوينا اجراءات كثيره
اشتغلنا مع البنك المركزي و كفريق عمل ما
بين البنوك عندنا والرومان الان يجلس فيها
كل البنوك موجودين جالسين جنب بعض لما
يصير حاله احتياري بل يكلم على بنك الرياض
يرد عليه الموظف حق بنك الرياض يقول له
حولوا طلع مبلغ مني كده حلوين يروح لزميله
اللي في البنك الاخر
الحمد لله هذه ساعدت كثير اجراءات
التحويلات الخارجيه وقفت 24 ساعه ما تطلع
نفس اليوم تقعد 24 ساعه تاكد انه ما في
بلاغ على الاحتيال عليها لكن جت على شويه
على تجربه العميد صح فبالتالي يعني عملاء
طولوا بالكم انا صحيح يعني تاثير على
تجربتكم 2013
المصرفي سهله ميسره ولما تقارنها اذا انت
عندك حساب في بريطانيا ولا فرنسا ولا في
امريكا ولا في صح حتى في دول الشرق الاوسط
لمتقدمه تلف علينا القطاع المصري في خدمات
افضل بكثير ما نبغى نرجع كثير لكن نبغينا
برضو نحمي همم المتعامدين وان شاء الله
يعني مرحله تعدي على خير باذن الله ونرجع
ان شاء الله في تقديم خدمات
هل يوجد شيء اسمه مصرف فيه اسلاميه
همم
تقريبا قريب من مئه في المئه من تعاملاتنا
في المصرفيه الافراد يتعاملات مصرفيه
اسلاميه
في يعني انا اتذكر صاله الشيخ المطلق نفس
السؤال
وقال لي اعطاني مثال يعني جميل قال لك لما
انت عازم ضيف
وعندك عاملين عامل مسلم وعامل غير مسلم
اللي ضحى او ذبح الذبيحه المسلم مسمى او
ذبحها الاجنبي
هاي صارت حلال صحيح
ابي اقول لك هذه خذها على المسرح نوقف هنا
طيب السؤال الاخير ااه يعني انا كنت اتعشى
مع مجموعه من الزملاء وقلت لهم في القطاع
المصرفي يعني بعض اصدقاء الجامع يشترون في
عده بنوك فواحد منهم جاء يعني قلت لها
بقابل بخالد وش في بالكم قال همم اللي
سواه ابو خالد في بنك الرياض اللي كانت
اشبه باداره حكوميه جهاز حكومي كده تقليدي
الى بنك حديث
يستحق اننا نسلط عليه الضوء وممكن نختزل
هذا الضوء بس سؤال بسيط
مش اهم درس
تعلمت في رحله التحول الخمرات الماضيه
اللي مرته فيها طيب اول شيء بس خليني ارجع
لمداخلتك وما نختزل لنجاح هذا في ابو خالد
النجاح هذا وراه دعم كبير من مجلس الاداره
وراه رغبه جاده من كل الزملاء والزميلات
في بنك الرياض للنجاح لا يمكن ينجح شخص
واحد ابدا اا
اذا بنظر
للخمس سنوات الماضيه يعني
خمس سنوات الماضيه
ابا يمكن
تفرقت لجزئيا انه هو لا تهمل قدره الانسان
في تحقيق نجاح والتغيير مكن الناس واعطهم
الصلاحيات وحاسبه
يعني اذا اذا ما اعطيت الانسان القدره انه
يتحرك ما اعطيته لاسرتي انه يتحرك
لن ينجح ولن تنجح المنظمه كامله يمكن اهم
شيء ركزني عليه انه خليه يكون ثقه موجوده
في زملائنا نعطيهم الصلاحيه نمكنهم لكن
نحاسبهم يمكن هذه اللي سواء في مرحله
المراحل ما نجحنا فيها لكنها لما نجحنا
فيها هي كانت اكبر لها اكبر اكثر في تغيير
همم بنك الرياض ونجاحات اللي تمت والطريق
طويل للنجاح باذن الله لازال امامنا يعني
اكثر من سوينا ان شاء الله
شكرا جزيلا الله يسعدك شكرا لكم شكرا لكم
شكرا في هذا القصير في اعداد وانتاج
الحلقه ياسر الغانم وياسر الكاميرا في
تسجيل الصوت عبد العزيز المزيد وفي
التحرير محمد الديني وفي الهندسه الصوتيه
محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف على الانتاج هذا
سقراط احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر
والتوزيع
[موسيقى]